One second. Hello? Oh, you got a phone call. I'm just doing this intro thing with Sean. With Sean from, yeah. Hey, you want to finish with me first and then take a call? One second, Sean. This is very important. Yes, host of the year. Sean, he's...
等一下。喂？哦，你接了个电话。我正在和肖恩做开场呢。和肖恩一起，对。嘿，你想先跟我聊完再去接电话吗？等一下，肖恩。这非常重要。没错，年度最佳主持人。肖恩，他……
Why don't we start the show? Sean, one second. I'm going to be there. Why are you so... Why don't we just start the show and then you can take a call? This is an important business call. Just give me one second. Yeah, I'm just chilling. What's going on with you? Guys, welcome to Smartlist. Smart!
我们为什么不开始节目呢？肖恩，等一下。我马上就来。你为什么这么……我们为什么不直接开始节目，然后你再去接电话？这是一个重要的商务电话。等我一下下。好吧，我很放松。你最近怎么样？伙计们，欢迎来到Smartless。聪明！
Smart! Smart! Smart! Smart! Smart! All right, real quick announcement here, right up at the top. Good news, bad news kind of thing. Dark day for sweet Willie Arnett.
聪明！聪明！聪明！聪明！聪明！好了，快速宣布一个消息，就在节目开头。算是个好坏参半的消息吧。对于可爱的威利·阿奈特来说真是黑暗的一天。
It's a bummer, we're not gonna, because of everything that's going on in the world, we are unfortunately gonna have to cancel our Toronto shows. So sorry to all our Toronto friends. And just so people understand, it's due to current capacity restrictions and the uncertain timeline of those limitations that we have to cancel the Toronto show.
真遗憾，我们不能，由于世界上发生的一切，我们不幸不得不取消多伦多演唱会。非常对不起我们所有的多伦多朋友。为了让大家明白，是因为当前的容量限制以及这些限制的不确定时间表，我们不得不取消多伦多演唱会。
And they can get refunds, right? Yes, the good news is that a refund will be processed automatically if you bought tickets. If you bought tickets directly from Ticketmaster, I think is the caveat. But let's tell them where we're going instead. The new city is. Washington DC.
他们可以退款，对吧？是的，好消息是如果你买过票，退款将自动处理。如果你直接从Ticketmaster买的票，我想这是个前提条件。但我们告诉他们我们要去哪里吧。新的城市是。华盛顿特区。
Wait, what? Yes, February 2nd. The same day as the Toronto show, but now since we're now doing Toronto, we're doing DC February 2nd at D.A.R. Constitution Hall in D.C. And for our listeners, you can use the special password Tracey,
等等，什么？是的，2月2日。和多伦多演唱会同一天，但既然我们现在不去多伦多，我们要去特区，2月2日在特区的D.A.R.宪法大厅。对于我们的听众，你可以使用特殊密码Tracey，
T-R-A-C-E-Y to buy tickets now until Thursday at 10 p.m. before they go on sale for the public. And those tickets are already on sale. Yeah, so they can already get those tickets and you can go, if you go and you use the promo code Tracey, T-R-A-C-E-Y, you can get tickets now in advance of the public up till Thursday, is that right?
T-R-A-C-E-Y现在买票，直到周四晚上10点，在门票公开销售之前。而且那些票现在已经在售了。是的，所以他们现在就可以买到票，你可以去，如果你去并使用促销代码Tracey，T-R-A-C-E-Y，你现在就可以在公众开售前买到票，一直到周四，对吗？
Yeah, so now until Thursday for all our listeners, use the password T-R-A-C-E-Y. You can also go to smartlist.com slash tour for tickets and more information. Smartlist.com slash tour. Never go to the post office again. So we're very sorry, Toronto. We love you, Canada.
是的，所以现在到周四，针对我们所有的听众，使用密码T-R-A-C-E-Y。你也可以去 smartlist.com 斜杠 tour 买票和获取更多信息。Smartlist.com 斜杠 tour。再也不用去邮局了。所以我们非常抱歉，多伦多。我们爱你，加拿大。
We will return. We love you so much. We know we have a lot of fans in Toronto and D.C., we can't wait to see you at Constitution Hall and that's great in February 2nd. And anyway, let's get to the show. Let's get to the show. Let's get to the show.
我们会回来的。我们太爱你们了。我们知道我们在多伦多和华盛顿特区有很多粉丝，我们迫不及待地想在宪法大厅见到你们，2月2日这太棒了。总之，我们开始节目吧。开始节目吧。开始节目吧。
This is odd, isn't it? We're doing a little Monday matinee. Listen, I've got shoes on. I don't think I've had shoes on for how many episodes have we done now? Yeah. It's the first one. And you're wearing a nice crew neck.
这很奇怪，对吧？我们在搞一个周一的日场秀。听着，我穿着鞋呢。我不认为我穿过鞋，我们现在已经做了多少集了？对。这是第一集。而且你穿着一件漂亮的圆领衫。
Yeah, well, I dare you, it's a sweater. Yeah, I guess. That's what I mean, it's a crew neck sweater. It looks like a cash sweater. It is cash. It's a crew neck sweater. You guys are also wearing, Will, you're wearing a crew neck sweater.
对，好吧，我敢打赌，这是一件毛衣。对，我猜。这就是我的意思，这是一件圆领毛衣。它看起来像一件开司米毛衣。它就是开司米。这是一件圆领毛衣。你们也穿着，威尔，你穿着一件圆领毛衣。
Slight V. Slight crew neck and Sean's wearing a Henley collar. But he's wearing a Henley with a T-shirt. Is it a sweater? We all have T-shirts under. We all have T-shirts under. Yeah, isn't that interesting? We all grew up on TV being dressed by costumers.
微微的V领。微微的圆领，肖恩穿着亨利领。但他穿的是一件带T恤的亨利衫。这是毛衣吗？我们里面都穿着T恤。我们里面都穿着T恤。对，这不有趣吗？我们都是看电视长大的，服装师给我们穿衣服。
They like to put a little collar T-shirt underneath the sweater. That's so true, we love T-shirts under our sweater. My T-shirt is a slight V. It's not really a V. If you want to get into it, this is a handkerchief. You know, when the Hogan family was over, that was a show I was in for a few years.
他们喜欢在毛衣里面穿一件带领子的T恤。太对了，我们喜欢在毛衣里穿T恤。我的T恤是个小V领。其实不算V领。如果你非要纠结的话，这是一条手帕。你知道的，当霍根一家来的时候，那是我演了几年的一个节目。
And I'm out, guys, I'm out. No, listen, so back in the Hogan family. We're not rolling yet. So when they were done with the show, they said, hey, would you like any of the wardrobe that your character wore? And I said, yeah, how much can I take? And they said, well, tell us what you don't want.
我退出了，伙计们，我退出了。不，听着，回到霍根一家。我们还没开始录呢。所以当他们拍完节目时，他们说，嘿，你想要你角色穿过的任何戏服吗？我说，行，我能拿多少？他们说，好吧，告诉我们你不要什么。
And I said, well, I'm not sure I don't want any of it. Can I have all of it? And they said, sure. So my whole wardrobe for, well, really, until I got with Amanda was all David Hogan stuff. Hogan family, and it still fit? Yeah, it did still fit for a bit. Would it fit now?
我说，嗯，我不确定我什么都不要。我能全部都要吗？他们说，当然。所以我的整部剧的戏服，直到我和阿曼达在一起，基本上都是大卫·霍根的东西。霍根一家，现在还穿得下？对，确实还能穿一会儿。现在还能穿吗？
It would, yes. I think it would. You know what, the same thing they offered, well, now they offer, if you want any of the wardrobe, you have to buy it. Yeah, that's a really tacky thing, I think, that production companies are doing nowadays. I don't have that.
可以，是的。我想可以。你知道吗，他们提供的也一样，现在他们提供的是，如果你想要任何戏服，你得买。是的，我认为这是现在制作公司在做的非常俗气的事情。我没有那个。
And they sell all the props and all the furniture and all the clothes. And it's like, hey, hey, let's easy with the tacky garage sale. Sean, I'll tell you, when we first did Arrested Development, hang on, I was getting to it. I just wanted to have a nice pause. When we were first doing Arrested Development, we used to, Jason and I, especially
他们卖掉所有的道具、所有的家具和所有的衣服。就像是，嘿，嘿，别弄什么俗气的旧货出售了。肖恩，我告诉你，当我们刚拍《发展受阻》时，等等，我正要说到这。我只是想好好停顿一下。当我们刚拍《发展受阻》时，杰森和我，特别是
amongst everybody in the cast, would have our sides. And for Tracy, I think we've been through sides. Oh, no, tell Tracy what sides are. Whatever scenes you're shooting that day, they print out those scenes so that you can have quick access to those scenes for your lines of dialogue. And they make them smaller if you'd like them to, so you can kind of carry them around easily.
在演员阵容中的所有人里，会有我们的台词页。至于特雷西，我想我们已经讨论过台词页了。哦，不，告诉特雷西什么是台词页。无论你那天拍什么场景，他们都会打印出那些场景，以便你能快速查阅这些场景的台词。如果你愿意，他们会把它们做小一点，这样你可以很方便地随身携带。
And Jason and I would, we often had quite a bit of dialogue. We would quickly look at it, and then we'd be, especially in the model home set, we'd jam them in the couch, our sides, would they go rolling? Here we go, guys, we're rolling. We just couldn't take a last look at that one, and jam it in the couch to do the scene. So years later, we go back to start doing the Netflix season,
杰森和我经常会有相当多的台词。我们会快速浏览一下，然后我们会，尤其是在样品房布景里，把它们塞进沙发里，我们的台词页，它们会滚来滚去吗？我们开始吧，伙计们，我们在录了。我们只是无法对那个进行最后一眼的查看，然后把它塞进沙发里来拍戏。所以多年后，我们回去开始拍网飞季，
like season four, and they bring all, and they had some of that, all that old stuff that they had in storage, and they bring the couch. And Jason, I don't know if you remember, we, you and I went in the first day, we had to do like a 12-page two-person scene that was insane, that Mitch had changed the dialogue first day, and we were like, trying to remember,
比如第四季，他们把所有的东西都拿来了，他们把储藏室里的那些旧东西都拿来了，他们把沙发也带来了。杰森，我不知道你记不记得，我们，你和我第一天进去，我们得拍一个12页的双人戏，太疯狂了，米奇第一天就改了台词，我们当时在努力回忆，
get to the couch, and I'm like, huh, reach in. And there are all these sides in there, all these sides from like eight years before. We had a terrible housekeeper on the show. Yeah, we really did. We would do that too, like all around the set, we'd just like hide, line this up, I'd write him on the table, and you know,
走到沙发那儿，我说，嗯，伸手进去。里面有所有的台词页，所有大约八年前的台词页。我们在剧组有一个糟糕的管家。是的，确实如此。我们也会那样做，在布景周围，我们只是把台词藏起来，把这个排好，我把台词写在桌子上，你知道的，
Ted Danson's famous for keeping his script behind the bar. So if ever he looks down, he's looking at his pages. Oh really? But no kidding. He's not working the ice, huh? That was sometimes you might. Guys, let's get to it. What an extraordinary person we have today.
泰德·丹森以把剧本藏在吧台后面而闻名。所以如果他向下看，他就是在看他的页数。哦，真的吗？但说真的。他不是在处理冰块吧？有时你可能会。伙计们，我们开始吧。我们今天迎来了一位多么非凡的人啊。
This little girl got her start on, This little girl got her start on a local puppet show called Hickory Hideout. And then because of that impressive credit, it made sense her next move would be on the hit NBC drama, Crossing Jordan, and then went on to steal scenes in Parks and Rec, Transparent, and on and on,
这个小女孩是从，这个小女孩是从一个叫“希科里藏身处”的当地木偶秀开始起步的。然后因为这个令人印象深刻的资历，她的下一步是在热门NBC电视剧《逝者能言》中出演顺理成章，接着在《公园与游憩》、《透明人生》等作品中大抢风头，
and in films she has incredible roles in How to Lose a Guy in 10 Days, Anchorman, tons of other great comedies, as well as amazing dramas like The Last Memsy, Revolutionary Road. But her latest gig, which I'm a huge fan of, was from the Marvel world, starring as the amazing villain,
在电影中她在《十日拍拖手册》、《王牌播音员》中扮演了令人难以置信的角色，还有无数其他伟大的喜剧，以及像《革命之路》这样惊人的正剧。但她最近的作品，我是它的超级粉丝，来自漫威世界，饰演了令人惊叹的反派，
Agatha Harkness in WandaVision. It's the illustrious Catherine Hawn, who I don't know. Wait a minute. Wait a minute. Wait, you guys. Oh, gosh. Our Catherine Hawn? Yeah, why is she your guest?
《旺达幻视》中的阿加莎·哈克尼斯。这就是杰出的凯瑟琳·哈恩，我不认识她。等一下。等一下。等等，你们。噢，天哪。我们的凯瑟琳·哈恩？是的，为什么她是你的嘉宾？
Our Catherine Hawn, you guys. Catherine, how dare you come in on Sean's list? Why, you should have called me and said, before I say yes to Sean, I just want to make sure you're good with me not being your guest. Well, I'm also really like, everything about this is cute.
我们的凯瑟琳·哈恩，伙计们。凯瑟琳，你怎么敢上肖恩的节目？为什么，你本该打电话给我说，在我答应肖恩之前，我只是想确保你介意我不是你的嘉宾。好吧，我也真的很喜欢，关于这一切的一切都很可爱。
First of all, that it's a paper towel that I was over your camera. Yeah, not just camera off, but just that I'm supposed to hold a paper towel. So I saw you're cute. Look at your all dressed the same today. Yeah, we dressed up for you today. We literally dressed exactly the same through this.
首先，我盖在你摄像头上的是一张纸巾。是的，不仅是关掉摄像头，而是我得拿着一张纸巾。所以我看到你很可爱。看你们今天穿得一模一样。是的，我们今天为你盛装打扮了。我们简直穿得一模一样。
It's all of us dead, kind of. Look at all of us. Oh, yeah, you're in the same. Well, it's kind of rainy here, isn't it? Yeah, it's all cozy and rainy. Well, Sean, would you guys mind taking a tight 60 minute break and just let me hang out with Catherine for a bit?
我们基本上都死了一样。看看我们所有人。哦，对，你穿得一样。好吧，这儿有点下雨，不是吗？是的，又舒适又下雨。好吧，肖恩，你们介意休息一个紧凑的60分钟，让我和凯瑟琳待一会儿吗？
Sure, sure, sure. I think I may like her more than both of you guys. Put together, yeah. We have a lot of catching up to do. We really do. I know, Catherine, I don't know. I think we met a long time ago. Come on, thank you for having me.
当然，当然，当然。我想我可能比你们两个更喜欢她。加起来，是的。我们有很多话要聊。真的有很多。我懂，凯瑟琳，我不知道。我想我们很久以前就认识了。来吧，谢谢你邀请我。
Yes, yes. We did. Yeah, a long time ago. And we share a very good mutual friend. Well, don't gloss over that. Where did you guys meet a long time ago? What was that event? You might remember it differently, but I remember it was like,
是的，是的。我们认识。是的，很久以前。我们有一个非常好的共同朋友。好吧，别一笔带过。你们很久以前在哪里见面的？那是什么活动？你们可能记不太一样，但我记得就像是，
when I was doing Crossing Jordan, there was an NBC party, maybe at 30 Rock. Yeah, sure. And then we ended up at a bar called Names and Faces. Yeah. Sounds great. Right by what we used to call the Regal Beagle, the Regal Royale.
我在拍《逝者能言》的时候，有一个NBC的派对，可能在30号大楼。没错。然后我们在一个叫“名字与面孔”的酒吧结束了。听起来不错。就在我们过去常称为“皇家比格犬”、“皇家雷尔”的地方旁边。
Was it called Names and Faces? Yes. It's right next to the act. Names and Faces. Jason would have, he has problems with both of those things. Yes. They don't let him in. They don't let him in.
它叫“名字与面孔”吗？对。它就在那个旁边。名字与面孔。杰森对此，他对这两件事都有问题。是的。他们不让他进。他们不让他进。
Wait, Catherine, quick question. Just starting out to speed up your story, but how long did it take to cross Jordan? Oh, I'm still crossing Jordan. Okay, okay. No, she never got across. By the way. Seven seasons.
等等，凯瑟琳，问个快问题。为了加快你的故事进度，拍《逝者能言》花了多长时间？哦，我还在拍《逝者能言》。好吧，好吧。不，她从来没拍完。顺便说一下。七季。
That's what kept it going. Just for the record. If I made that joke, Will wouldn't talk to me for a week. Yeah, Will makes it and I laugh my ass off. Well, it's how you make it. It depends on what time of the year you're gonna cross Jordan in.
这就是它能持续的原因。为了记录在案。如果我开那个玩笑，威尔会一个星期不跟我说话。是的，威尔开玩笑，我笑死。好吧，这取决于你怎么开玩笑。这取决于你在一年中的什么时候去《逝者能言》。
If it's a winter, it's gonna get tough winters over there. Wait, you're in your house, but it looks like you're in a record store or something. What's happening? It does look, yeah, it does. You look like the... I don't know if I was just in a record store, you guys.
如果是冬天，那里的冬天会变得很艰难。等等，你在你家里，但看起来你像在唱片店什么的。怎么回事？看起来，是的，确实。你看上去像……我不知道我刚才是不是在唱片店，伙计们。
I'm living up my high fidelity dreams. Are you in the set of this? I'm in my garage, guys. I don't know what to tell you. What do you do? Paint or what's going on? Is it a gal cave? You guys, can I tell you a very funny story?
我正在实现我的高保真梦想。你在那个布景里吗？我在我的车库里，伙计们。我不知道该对你们说什么。你在画画还是在干嘛？这是个女人洞穴吗？伙计们，我能给你们讲个非常搞笑的故事吗？
Is that Sean had asked me to do this before and I was the guest that had to bail last minute. That's okay. That was you. You had to bail last minute? I was in Serbia and it was late at night, my time. And my, my headphone jacks. This is my headphone, they wouldn't work.
肖恩以前曾邀请我做这个节目，我是那个最后时刻放鸽子的人。没关系。原来是你。你不得不最后时刻鸽掉？我在塞尔维亚，那时我的时间已经很晚了。我的，我的耳机插孔。这是我的耳机，它们就是不工作。
And turns out, all I needed to do is... It should be noted that you just made the universal sign for... Master bass jacking off. Pulling a rope down, Jason. Well, needless to say, all I had to do was turn the computer on and off, apparently. But I was on such a frenzy
结果证明，我唯一需要做的是……应该指出的是，你刚刚做了那个通用的手势……打飞机。向下拉绳子，杰森。好吧，不用说，我唯一需要做的事情显然就是把电脑开关重启一次。但我当时太疯狂了，
and your tech team was so patient with me. But it would have been really goddamn cute because I was shooting a film. We were having our rap party on the roof and the lead actor was like, you're not getting away with this. And so he had like brought, like in the middle of what would have been our podcast,
你们的技术团队对我太有耐心了。但这本该非常他妈的可爱，因为我正在拍一部电影。我们在屋顶举行杀青派对，男主角就像是，你可逃不掉这个。所以他带了，就像在我们的播客本该进行的当中，
he like brought, it was Daniel Craig and he was gonna bring like force me to answer the door and get a glass of champagne during our podcast. Which would have been real goddamn cute. For the crossing Jordan movie? Yes. We were shooting it in Serbia. It's a long story, Will, but Daniel Craig's in it.
他带来，那是丹尼尔·克雷格，他要带人逼我开门，在我们的播客期间拿一杯香槟。这本该真他妈的可爱。为了《逝者能言》电影？是的。我们在塞尔维亚拍摄。说来话长，威尔，但丹尼尔·克雷格在里面。
Is Jill Hennessey have anything to do with it? I shouldn't have said it. Crossing Jordan movie, everybody's been waiting. Names and faces. Faces and names. All right, Nat, haven't you done some light hanging with Mr. Bond? Daniel Craig, I did years ago.
吉尔·海尼西跟这有关系吗？我不该说这个的。《逝者能言》电影，每个人都在等待。名字与面孔。面孔与名字。好吧，娜特，你没跟邦德先生有过轻松的交往吗？丹尼尔·克雷格，我多年前见过。
We went to a Super Bowl party and then he said, let's go to... Hey, wait a second, Will. Did you just wake up from a nap? Look at the back of your head again. Hang on a second. I know, I did. Did you really?
我们去了一个超级碗派对，然后他说，我们去……嘿，等一下，威尔。你刚从小睡中醒来吗？再看看你的后脑勺。等一下。我知道，我确实睡了。你真的睡了？
I did. That's why he's on fire. Listener, it's three o'clock on a Monday and Will just got up. Can you tell me something, Will? Yeah, me too. You did, right? You guys are the worst.
我睡了。这就是他火大的原因。听众们，周一三点钟，威尔刚醒来。威尔，你能告诉我点什么吗？对，我也是。你睡了吧，对吧？你们是最糟糕的。
You guys, I'm gonna shake it up for you. It really is. Don't wake them up yet. And I appreciate you doing this at a three o'clock on a Monday. Okay, let's get back to Serbia. I wanna go to Serbia. How was shooting in Serbia?
伙计们，我要给你们换点新花样。确实如此。先别叫醒他们。我很感激你们在周一三点钟做这个。好吧，我们回到塞尔维亚。我想去塞尔维亚。在塞尔维亚拍戏怎么样？
Quick trip. You were in Serbia with D Craig. What was it? It was Knives Out. We did some stuff there for the second Knives Out. Oh, great. Right. And third, right?
快闪之旅。你和D·克雷格在塞尔维亚。那是什麽？那是《利刃出鞘》。我们在那里为第二部《利刃出鞘》拍了一些东西。哦，太棒了。对。还有第三部，对吧？
Just the second. But there's two and three, right? But there's gonna be a third. You get killed in the second one. There we go, spoiler alert. We got it. I love that movie. So, Catherine, you get shot or knifed?
只有第二部。但有第二部和第三部，对吧？但会有第三部。你在第二部里被杀了。好了，剧透警告。我们知道了。我喜欢那部电影。所以，凯瑟琳，你被枪击还是被刀刺了？
You get knifed probably in the second one. But just blown up in the trunk of the car. No! Why are they shooting in Serbia? I can't say anything. No, Jason, what are you doing? By the way, in Australia, it's called That's Not a Knives Out.
你可能在第二部里被刀刺了。但只是在车后备箱里被炸了。不！为什么他们在塞尔维亚拍戏？我什么都不能说。不，杰森，你在干什么？顺便说一下，在澳大利亚，它叫“那不是利刃出鞘”。
That's Not a Knife. That's not a Knife. All right, so you're in part two, but not in part three. I mean, yeah. You don't know. We don't know. But they do a new cast for every, I guess, Knives Out. So, except for Daniel.
那不是刀。那不是刀。好吧，所以你在第二部里，但不在第三部里。我是说，对。你不知道。我们不知道。但他们每部都换新演员，我猜《利刃出鞘》是这样的。所以，除了丹尼尔。
Daniel's the one connecting. But you're tech avail, LA. Listen, I will tell them I'm tech avail. Means technically available. Put a different wig on her. Who knows? How did you like working in Serbia? Serbia, this is what I'll tell you about.
丹尼尔是那个连接点。但你是技术上可用，洛杉矶。听吧，我会告诉他们我有技术空档。意思是技术上可用。给她换个假发。谁知道呢？你在塞尔维亚工作得怎么样？塞尔维亚，这是我要对你说的。
I loved Serbia. However, I haven't been eating much meat lately. If you like day old cheese, pour it over dear Serbia. Is your place. I served you by a guy in a Sergio Tikini tracksuit like that, right? Oh my God, which are so rad. And let me tell you, I got a couple from my son,
我喜欢塞尔维亚。然而，我最近没有吃太多肉。如果你喜欢陈年奶酪，倒在亲爱的塞尔维亚上面。是你的地方。一个穿着塞尔吉奥·蒂基尼运动服的家伙给你上菜，对吧？哦，天哪，太酷了。我跟你说，我给我儿子买了一套，
and he is wearing them proudly. I can serve you this food, or also I might have a piece under here, too. Also, there's a lot of like, at baggage claim, people just full on smoking cigarettes inside, just waiting for their luggage in the airport. I mean, they smoke in the elevator in Serbia, I think. Yeah.
他正骄傲地穿着呢。我可以给你端上这些食物，或者我这里也可能有一块。还有，有很多像，在行李提取处，人们直接在室内抽烟，在机场等待他们的行李。我是说，我觉得他们在塞尔维亚的电梯里都抽烟。对。
Oh yeah, for sure. Bless them. For sure. But it is, but it's actually like a gorgeous, like really beautiful, really beautiful graffiti. Will and I went to Istanbul, Turkey once, and when we got off the plane and in the airport, they put, I don't know why, they put us on that little truck
哦，是的，绝对。上帝保佑他们。绝对。但它是，但它实际上像是一个华丽的，真的很漂亮，非常漂亮的涂鸦。威尔和我去过一次土耳其伊斯坦布尔，当我们下飞机在机场时，他们把我们，不知道为什么，把我们放在那个小卡车上，
that drives you through the airport in the sea of, and I'm not exaggerating, a million people. Yeah, we go through. Like, beep, beep, beep, beep, and me and Joe. Did you guys look particularly bloated when you got off the plane or something? Why'd they put you on the truck? I don't know.
载着你穿过机场，在一片汪洋中，我没有夸张，有一百万人。对，我们穿过去。就像，哔，哔，哔，哔，我和乔。你们下飞机时看起来特别浮肿还是怎么的？他们为什么把你们放在卡车上？我不知道。
I don't know. Not everybody's worried about bloat 24-7, baby. And they don't put people on an ambulatory golf cart. Is it about the bloat? All right, so, Catherine, back to you. How long were you in Serbia for? Not that long. We were in Greece for a big chunk of it,
我不知道。并不是每个人都24小时担心浮肿，宝贝。他们不把人放在救护高尔夫球车上。这是关于浮肿吗？好吧，所以，凯瑟琳，回到你身上。你在塞尔维亚待了多久？没那么久。我们在希腊待了很大一部分时间，
which was the best, which was awesome. That was like the beginning of the summer. And I was having it, and I'd never been there before, and I literally got there and I felt like, immediately I was like 67 years old, just like with an overall strap off. I was just like, I was like, I was Mamma Mia City. I loved it so much.
那是最好的，太棒了。那就像是夏天刚开始的时候。我当时在享受，我以前从没去过那里，我字面意思上一到那里就立刻觉得自己像个67岁的老人，简直就像把背带放下来。我当时就像是，我简直是“妈妈咪呀”之城。我太喜欢了。
In Greece. I was so into it. I was like, leather up the skin. Like, I was so down. I loved it. What part of Greece were you in? There's some great spots in Greece. Yes, we were in a really off the beaten path,
在希腊。我太沉迷了。我当时就想，给皮肤抹上皮革油。我是说，我太投入了。我太喜欢了。你在希腊的什么地方？希腊有些很棒的地方。是的，我们在一个真正人迹罕至的地方，
kind of like three hours north, or I guess maybe, I guess it was more, it was like three hours outside of Athens. It kind of felt like the big syrup. So you're coming off the main highway. Catherine, you think our listener doesn't know, they don't know shit about anything. Are the people dumb enough to listen to this?
大概在北边三小时，或者我想也许，我觉得更远一点，大概离雅典三小时。感觉有点像大糖浆。所以你要下主高速公路。凯瑟琳，你觉得我们的听众不知道，他们对什么都一无所知。这些人们够蠢到听这个吗？
I love your listeners. Especially Tracy. I want to hear your idea of listeners. Tracy's got, well, how did she get so dumb? Tracy, I'm with you. It's pretty good. She's part of the football. Why are they so cruel to you?
我爱你们的听众。特别是特雷西。我想听听你对听众的看法。特雷西有，嗯，她怎么变得这么蠢的？特雷西，我跟你一伙的。这挺不错的。她是橄榄球的一部分。他们为什么对你这么残酷？
We loved Tracy. We love her. We took little, we took little air, we took little taxis to like, Spetsis or Hydra were islands we visited. We never went to like the party islands. Did the kids or Ethan make it out there? Yeah, they were with me the whole time.
我们爱特雷西。我们爱她。我们乘小飞机，我们乘小出租车去了斯佩察岛或九头蛇岛这样的岛屿。我们从不去那种派对岛。孩子们或伊森赶去那儿了吗？对，他们一直跟我在一起。
Come on. Oh, that's nice. Yeah, and then Leonard and Ethan went, they went home early, so they could, you know, Leonard could have his first, like the camp, sleepover camp. How's that going? 15 for him, right?
拜托。哦，那太好了。对，然后伦纳德和伊森走了，他们提前回家了，为了让，你知道的，伦纳德能有他的第一次，比如夏令营，寄宿夏令营。进展怎么样？他15岁了吧，对吧？
Which you said 15? Yeah, it's good. Actually like much better than middle school. I don't know if you feel the same, but I feel like a cloud like lifted. Middle school is tough. Middle school is rough. It's rough.
你刚才说15岁？对，挺好的。实际上比初中好得多。我不知道你们是否有同感，但我感觉像是一片乌云被移开了。初中很难熬。初中很艰难。很难熬。
I'm glad that Franny missed the bulk of that. She missed seventh and eighth. And I think, aren't they both in the same class? They're the same class. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. Middle school or what Jason calls high school, right? It was the same, yeah.
我很高兴弗兰妮错过了大部分那种时期。她错过了七年级和八年级。我想，他们不都在同一个班吗？他们是同一个班。对，没错。对。初中或者杰森所说的高中，对吧？是一样的，对吧。
Or just the end. Middle school was. For me, yeah. Yeah. Or not even. Almost made it, is what I call high school. Jason, don't you dare. Well, listen, I was busy chasing my passion.
或者只是最后。初中就是。对我来说，是。对。甚至都不是。勉强撑过去，这就是我所说的高中。杰森，你敢。好吧，听着，我当时忙着追逐我的激情。
You were earning. Yeah, I was doing some fifties dance in Teen Wolf 2. Somebody said, hey, here's your diploma. And Jason said, what do I need a diploma for? He sped off in a 9-11, you know? So. And all went downhill. Catherine, listen, I want to talk to you about your start
你在赚钱。对，我在《少狼2》里跳五十年代的舞蹈。有人说，嘿，这是你的毕业文凭。杰森说，我还要文凭干嘛？他开着一辆911绝尘而去，你知道吗？所以。然后一切走下坡路。凯瑟琳，听着，我想跟你聊聊你的起步
and everything because I'm really interested in that and you grew up. Let's get the interview started. It's 20 minutes in already, Sean. I know. We gotta get to it. Sean, and by the way, Sean is our top interviewer on this program.
和一切，因为我对此真的很感兴趣，而且你是在那儿长大的。我们开始采访吧。肖恩，已经20分钟了。我知道。我们得抓紧了。肖恩，顺便说一句，肖恩是我们这个节目上的头号采访者。
Oh, God. Oh, I know. You guys, I love this dude. I love your podcast, by the way. Love it, so happy. Because you've got the world's greatest host on it. Go ahead, he willed right in. It is the worst.
哦，天哪。哦，我知道。伙计们，我爱这家伙。顺便说一句，我喜欢你们的播客。太喜欢了，非常高兴。因为你上面有世界上最伟大的主持人。来吧，他马上就接话了。这是最糟糕的。
Go ahead, tell Catherine. I mean, I'm the best. The world's nominated, go ahead. Sean, here he comes. Here comes one of his award-winning questions. Oh, God. How old were you when you started to act? Did your parents want you to get started?
来吧，告诉凯瑟琳。我是说，我是最棒的。获得世界提名的，来吧。肖恩，他来了。他那些获奖的问题之一来了。哦，天哪。你开始演戏时多大？你父母想让你入行吗？
How do you memorize all those lines? Don't start. Catherine, you know, the three of us host this thing. And the nice folks at iHeartRadio gave us a few nominations for their annual podcast recognition. Oh, they should have. And they singled out, young Sean P. Hayes, for host of the year.
你是怎么记住所有这些台词的？别开始了。凯瑟琳，你知道，我们三个主持这个节目。iHeartRadio的好心人为我们的年度播客表彰提供了一些提名。哦，他们应该的。他们特别指出了年轻的肖恩·P·海斯，荣获年度最佳主持人。
The worst part is that Sean sent us the article. Oh, he did. And I didn't read it. Under the caption of, good for us. Good for us. Exclamation point. And then Will said, sounds like good for you. And he goes, oh, I didn't read it all.
最糟糕的是肖恩把这篇文章发给我们了。哦，他发了。而我没看。标题是“我们真棒”。我们真棒。感叹号。然后威尔说，“听起来像是你真棒”。然后他说，“哦，我没看完”。
I didn't read it. I really didn't read it. Sean. Yeah, isn't that hilarious? And I'm like, check out the pictures of these Emmys. Oh, I didn't know I sent that. All right, so how'd you get started was the question, right, Sean?
我没看完。我真的没看完。肖恩。对，这不搞笑吗？我就像，看看这些艾美奖的照片。哦，我不知道是我发的。好吧，所以你是怎么开始的，这是问题，对吧，肖恩？
So how early? No, no, I want to know. Hang on, one second, I actually have a question. So when you come from a family where there's three kids, and we kind of ask this question a lot, because I'm interested. I was the youngest of five. A lot of people who are the youngest of siblings
那么有多早？不，不，我想知道。等一下，我其实有个问题。所以当你来自一个有三个孩子的家庭，我们经常问这个问题，因为我很感兴趣。我是五个孩子里最小的。很多作为家里最小的兄弟姐妹的人
feel they need the attention for the actor. But you were the oldest of three, which is rare. So what gives? So what? Yeah. What's with the French show in your life? Yeah, hey, weirdo. What?
觉得为了当演员他们需要更多的关注。但你是三个孩子里老大，这很少见。所以是怎么回事？所以呢？你的人生里怎么会有法国节目？等等，怪胎。什么？
Well, too much of a big shot to stick around and be an example for the young kids, huh? You had to get out of there. Sorry, Katherine, go ahead and finish swallowing your drink. Oh, my god. We almost got our first pet take. Almost.
好吧，太大牌了，不肯留下来给小孩子们做个好榜样，是吧？你得离开那儿。对不起，凯瑟琳，继续把你的饮料咽下去。噢，天哪。我们差点有了第一个宠物镜头。差点。
So even though you were the oldest, why did you get into showbiz? I'm actually interested in that question. I love you. Me too. You know, I grew up going to Catholic school. It was more of like a cultural thing for us than anything else. It was like the cheapest private school, to be honest.
所以尽管你是老大，你为什么会进入演艺圈？我其实对这个问题很感兴趣。我爱你。我也是。你知道，我在天主教学校长大。对我们来说，这与其说别的，不如说更像是一种文化现象。说实话，这是最便宜的私立学校。
And every Saturday, I would take classes at the Cleveland Playhouse, which has now kind of been mostly taken over by Case Western, the big hospital down there. But it was just like the most. I thought you were going to say mostly taken over by kangaroos or something. It's been mostly, now it's been overrun by kangaroos. What?
每周六，我都会去克利夫兰剧场上课，现在那里基本上已经被凯斯西储大学接管了，也就是那边的大医院。但这只是最……我以为你要说基本上被袋鼠什么的接管了。它基本上被，现在被袋鼠占领了。什么？
Yeah, no, I know. It's a long story. That's exactly what I was thinking too, Sean. Yeah, thanks. I thought you almost said kangaroos. Katherine, please just go ahead. Please go on. I'm so silly today.
对，不，我知道。说来话长。肖恩，我刚才也是这么想的。对，谢谢。我以为你差点说袋鼠。凯瑟琳，请继续。请继续。我今天太傻了。
It's because it's later. I love a matinee, guys. Now the matinee is yielding real fruit. Turns out the matinee is the only way to do it. OK, so the kangaroos are in the gym. What a clown show this is. What a. So far we can't use any of it.
因为时间比较晚。伙计们，我喜欢日场秀。现在日场秀正在结出真正的果实。事实证明，日场秀才是唯一的录制方式。好吧，所以袋鼠在健身房里。这真是一场小丑秀。这。到目前为止，我们什么都用不上。
None of it's usable. We're 25 minutes in. OK. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. OK, so you found a passion there at the Catholic School for acting. And then, OK, so what was the first big job?
没有什么是可用的。我们已经进行25分钟了。好吧。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。好吧，所以你在天主教学校找到了对表演的热情。然后，好吧，第一份大工作是什么？
What did you, when did you know? I might be able to make a living at this. OK, my first big job. I played Salty the Psalm book. And it was a, I played a Psalm book at the church. It was like, I wore a cardboard box, and they painted it to look like a Psalm book. Oh, no.
你做了什么，你什么时候知道？我或许能靠这个谋生。好吧，我的第一份大工作。我演了圣诗书索尔蒂。这是一个，我在教堂里演一本圣诗书。就像是，我穿着一个纸板箱，他们把它涂成圣诗书的样子。哦，不。
And I kind of stood in the middle of the church, and I would dance around. And it was like, apparently, it's a thing that they do in churches. I thought that it was just like a singular, you know, that we had written it for our, you know, for Saint Hans. But apparently, like, it goes, it's something that is in a lot of different, like, fundamental
我就站在教堂中间，到处跳舞。这就像是，显然，这是他们在教堂里做的一件事。我以为这只是一个独特的，你知道的，我们为我们的，你知道的，为了圣汉斯写的。但显然，这，这是全国许多不同，比如基础派
churches throughout the country. But I played Salty. Sean, you're familiar with this? No, not that. P-S-A-L-T-Y. Pasalty. Oh, I get it. Pasalty the Psalm book.
教堂里都有的东西。但我扮演索尔蒂。肖恩，你熟悉这个吗？不，不是那个。P-S-A-L-T-Y。索尔蒂。哦，我明白了。圣诗书索尔蒂。
Psalm book. And you felt like you nailed that particular piece, such that. No, I had a lot more to learn, Jason Bayman. Did you end up doing Psalm like it hot? Did you, did you guys ever do that? I mean, something's got to give. And this guy cannot get a nomination, OK? It's unbelievable.
圣诗书。你觉得自己把那个特定角色演得很完美，以至于……不，我还有很多要学的，杰森·贝曼。你最后演了《热情如火》吗？你们，你们做过那个吗？我是说，总得有个限度。而这家伙拿不到提名，对吧？这太不可思议了。
Now, that's high level shit right there. Hey, hey, you couldn't come within a mile of a joke like that. No, absolutely not. Fucking. I say kangaroos, and it goes cricket. Catherine, keep talking. I want to know, you went back to, you went to Northwest. From kangaroos to crickets, the Shawnee story.
现在，这才是高水平的扯淡。嘿，嘿，你连那种笑话的一英里之内都靠近不了。不，绝对不行。他妈的。我说袋鼠，结果一片死寂。凯瑟琳，继续说。我想知道，你回到了，你去了西北大学。从袋鼠到死寂，肖恩的故事。
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha. It's so stupid. This is my favorite. That's the worst. OK, so Catherine, wait a minute. I can't tell. You have to fire your publicist after this, Catherine. No.
哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈。太蠢了。这是我的最爱。太糟糕了。好吧，所以凯瑟琳，等一下。我看不出来。你得在这之后炒了你的公关，凯瑟琳。不。
So wait, you went to. Then I went to the Cleveland Playouts, and I just took classes, I was called a curtain puller there. But I didn't actually, apparently back in the day, they used to be able to pull the curtains. This is going to be such a boring story. No. But then I didn't get to.
所以等等，你去了。然后我去了克利夫兰剧场，我在那儿上课，我被称为那里的拉幕员。但我实际上没有，显然过去他们能拉幕。这会是个多么无聊的故事啊。不。但我没去成。
Well, walk us through it. OK, wait. And then you went to Northwestern. I know so many people that went to Northwestern University. It seems like so many famous people come out of there or went there, right? Did you love it there? Oh, sorry.
好吧，给我们讲讲。好吧，等一下。然后你去了西北大学。我认识好多去西北大学的人。似乎有那么多名人从那儿出来或者去过那儿，对吧？你在那儿过得开心吗？哦，抱歉。
Jumping forward to Northwestern. Sorry. Yeah. OK. That was about a 15-year jump. But I'm with it. Go ahead. Please.
跳到西北大学去了。抱歉。好吧。那是大约15年的跨越。但我跟上了。请继续。请。
Sorry. The job, she didn't get to pull the curtain, Jason. Right, right, right. And then we went to Northwestern. Unless you got another, what other jobs have you not gotten? OK, listen, I played, listen, in the middle there, in the middle there, I did Hickory Hideout. Yes, Hickory Hideout was the first, it was your puppet show.
抱歉。那个工作，她没能拉成幕，杰森。对，对，对。然后我们去了西北大学。除非你还有别的，你还有什么工作没得到？好吧，听着，我演了，听着，中间那会儿，中间那会儿，我演了《希科里藏身处》。是的，《希科里藏身处》是第一个，那是你的木偶秀。
Yes. How old were you when you did that? I was in fourth grade to sixth grade. And it was at our local news station. And we shared the space so they would like, it was, the tree house was always in the corner. And then on Saturdays, when they weren't doing the evening news, they would just roll out the tree house.
是的。你做那个的时候多大？我上四年级到六年级。它在我们的当地新闻台录制。我们共用一个空间，所以他们会像，树屋总是在角落里。然后在周六，当他们不做晚间新闻时，他们就会把树屋推出来。
I got to see footage of that. And it was me and two squirrels named Nutso and Shirley Squirrely. And an owl, puppet named Know-it-Owl. I loved that joke. And I played a character named Jenny. And I would knock on the tree house. And we would ask Nutso and Shirley.
我能看到那段录像。里面有我和两只松鼠，名叫纳特索和雪莉·斯奎莉。还有一个叫“万事通猫头鹰”的猫头鹰木偶。我喜欢那个笑话。我扮演一个叫珍妮的角色。我会敲树屋的门。我们会问纳特索和雪莉。
That sounds like a hoot. Yeah, Nutso. Beautiful. Now there, hey, who's in the game now? Good for you, Sean. Look who's thrown his hat in the ring. You know who watched that? You know who will watch that?
听起来很有趣。是的，纳特索。太棒了。现在，嘿，现在谁在局里？干得好，肖恩。看看谁把帽子扔进场里了。你知道谁看过那个吗？你知道谁会看那个吗？
Owl. Oh my god. Somebody just passed you. Boy, did you see him go by you there, Will? What he's hitting for the cycle right now. That was unbelievable. Whittly gets to by at the end of the episode. Barely keep up.
猫头鹰。哦，天哪。刚才有人超过你了。天哪，你看到他从你身边超过去了吗，威尔？他现在正为全垒打而击球呢。这太不可思议了。威特利在节目结束时买单。勉强跟上。
Go ahead, Catherine. So yeah, let's get to Northwestern. Fuck the tree house. You're six years old now. You're at Northwestern. So what happens at Northwestern? You go to some Wildcat games? I did not take in one Wildcat game.
继续，凯瑟琳。所以，是的，我们去西北大学吧。去他的树屋。你现在六岁了。你在西北大学。西北大学发生什么了？你去看了几场野猫队的比赛吗？我一场野猫队的比赛也没看。
But I met my husband. There we go. Oh, that's nice. My friend, my friend, my husband. How'd that go? Tell me about the first date. God, we. Hurry, goddammit.
但我遇到了我丈夫。这就对了。哦，那太好了。我的朋友，我的朋友，我的丈夫。进展怎么样？跟我讲讲第一次约会。天哪，我们。快点，该死的。
Because somebody shot at me real fast. We. Are you talking about the date? I remember we. Oh, Jesus. Sorry, we can cut that. I'm trying to get in on the quick jokes. Cut it.
因为有人朝我开枪，动作真快。我们。你在说约会吗？我记得我们。噢，耶稣。抱歉，我们可以剪掉那个。我想插进那些快节奏的笑话里。剪掉。
We're going to double it. Can I get in on the quick jokes? Double it, you guys. We were at the cafeteria. His plate was, I remember his tray was very neat. Mine was a disaster. Because I wanted to try everything on the buffet. That sounds like mine.
我们要加倍。我能插进快节奏的笑话里吗？加倍吧，伙计们。我们在自助餐厅。他的盘子，我记得他的托盘非常整洁。我的则是一场灾难。因为我想尝尝自助餐里的每一样东西。听起来像我的。
And he was very neat. I made a lot of fun of him. And the rest is history. Wait, so he was sliding. I honestly want to know this. So you guys are filling up your tray. You're next to each other in the line there? Or did you see him sitting alone at a table for one?
而他非常整洁。我狠狠地嘲笑了他一番。然后历史就这样诞生了。等等，所以他当时在滑动。老实说，我很想知道这个。所以你们在装满你们的托盘。你们在那里的队伍里挨着吗？还是你看到他独自坐在一张单人桌旁？
No, he was not sitting. No, he was not. OK, so you're sliding down the thing together. And you start making small talk while you're scooping stuff onto your plate. No, we had arrived at a table where there were other people sitting. And I was like, Jesus, because his tray was so
不，他没有坐着。不，他没有。好吧，所以你们一起顺着那个台子往前滑。当你们把东西舀到盘子里时，你们开始闲聊了吗？不，我们来到了一张坐着其他人的桌子旁。我就像，天哪，因为他的托盘太
neatly neat. And that was not a turn on or it was? It was. It was interesting to me because I had to try everything as if I had never been fed before in my life. I had piled everything that the cafeteria had offered onto my tray.
整洁了，太整洁了。那算是一种吸引还是反感？是吸引。这引起了我的兴趣，因为我得尝试所有东西，就像我这辈子从来没吃过饭一样。我把自助餐厅提供的一切都堆到了我的托盘上。
You wanted to get your money's worth. Absolutely. Did he have his great hair back then? Great hair. He's got great hair. Really, really great. Doesn't he have beautiful hair? Beautiful hair.
你想捞回本。绝对的。他那时候就有那种很棒的头发吗？很棒的头发。他有很棒的头发。真的，真的很棒。他不是有一头漂亮的头发吗？漂亮的头发。
Great hair. Now, when did you, because this is what I really want to know, you worked at a beauty salon. You've got to have like crazy, awesome, funny beauty salon like stories. Was that while you were in college, you worked at a beauty salon? It was after college, moved to New York,
头发真棒。那么，你是什么时候——因为这真的是我想知道的，你在美容院工作过。你一定经历过像疯狂、精彩、滑稽的美容院那种故事。那是你在上大学的时候吗，你在美容院工作？那是大学毕业后，搬到了纽约，
skipping ahead, worked at a hair salon called Garen New York that was out of Henry Bendall. So this was in 95. Copy. He was like one of those hair cutters that were charging like $300 for a haircut. And you were like, where was it? Where was the?
快进一下，在亨利·班德尔百货里的加仑纽约美发沙龙工作过。所以这是在95年。明白。他就像那种剪个头发要收300美金的理发师。然后你就——是在哪里？是在哪里？
What? I know that name, Harry. Where was his? Henry Bendall. It used to be on Fifth Avenue. It was like a very fancy little tea. It was like a crock, like Bergdorf's was right there. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
什么？我知道那个名字，哈里。他的店在哪里？亨利·班德尔。以前在第五大道。就像是一个非常高档的小茶室。就像是个百货店，伯格多夫百货就在旁边。对，对，对。
And were you assisting this stylist, not a hair cutter? No. They don't like to be called that. I was the receptionist. OK. My cousin George gave me the job. OK. My cousin George gave me the job.
那你是在给这位发型师打下手，而不是理发师？不是。他们不喜欢那样被称呼。我是前台接待。好的。我表哥乔治帮我找的工作。好的。我表哥乔治帮我找的工作。
Would you dabble with nails or hair or anything? No. In fact, I wore the same Banana Republic suit there every day, so much so that it turned shiny because I had to dry clean it so much. Do you know how you like? Oh, yeah, yeah. All the dudes got together to get me a Mason Pearson hair
你会顺便做做指甲或头发什么的吗？不会。事实上，我在那里每天都穿着同一套香蕉共和国的西装，以至于它都被穿得发亮了，因为我不得不经常干洗。你知道那种感觉吗？哦，对，对，对。所有的伙计们有一次过节时凑钱给我买了一把梅森·皮尔逊发
brush for the holidays one year because they were like, brush your hair. Because I was such a disaster working at the front desk. Because I would literally be like, I remember they would kind of try to experiment on me. Like, Sweet Garen gave me like Anne Bancroft, like Skunk Stripes, and Ethan. We had been living in like a one room, fifth floor walk-up,
刷，因为他们觉得：梳梳头吧。因为我在前台工作得实在太一团糟了。因为我真的会——我记得他们会试着在我身上做实验。比如，甜心加仑给我弄了安·班克罗夫特式的，像臭鼬一样的条纹，还有伊森。我们一直住在像是一个房间、五层楼没电梯的公寓里，
near Scores, so like on the east side. I don't know where that is. Right, right. It's a sports place, right? Anywhere near names and faces. Names and faces, faces and names. So because Sean jumped in, you and Ethan, you meet in the line at the cafeteria,
靠近斯克雷斯，就在东区。我不知道那在哪里。对，对。是个运动场所吧？在任何靠近“名字与面孔”附近的地方。“名字与面孔”，“面孔与名字”。所以因为肖恩插话了，你和伊森，你们在自助餐厅排队时相遇，
and all of a sudden now you're living in New York together. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. Sean, what? Because he just wants to hear about stories about people crapping their pants at the salon. But you know what I mean? Like, let's. No, you know where I'm going with this.
然后突然之间你们就一起在纽约生活了。哦，对，对，对。肖恩，什么？因为他只想听关于人们在沙龙里拉裤子里的故事。但你知道我的意思吗？就像，让我们。不，你知道我要说什么。
I want to know about theater in New York. Yeah, things went well in Northwestern with you and Ethan. And you said, hey, let's go east. Let's go to New York because I've got a passion for theater. And it seems like you have a passion for hair, Ethan. So why don't I get a job at a hair salon? No, that we kind of looked in the village voice
我想知道纽约的戏剧。对，你和伊森在西北大学的时候一切顺利。然后你说，嘿，我们去东部吧。我们去纽约吧，因为我对戏剧充满热情。伊森，看起来你对美发也充满热情。那我为什么不去美发沙龙找份工作呢？不，那是我们在西北大学时，
when we were at Northwestern that summer after graduating. We saw that there was like a hotel that was $60 a night. And we were like, great, got a U-Haul, went, saw the hotel, put our stuff in storage, saw the hotel. It was the Jane Street Hotel. Oh, yeah. Pre.
在毕业后的那个夏天，我们翻看《乡村之声》时看到的。我们看到有一家酒店只要60美元一晚。我们就想，太棒了，租了一辆U-Haul搬过去，去看那家酒店，把东西存好，然后看了那家酒店。那是简街酒店。哦，对。前
Pre-cool. Head wig. Yeah. So it was like pre-becoming like a hip place. It was rough. Yeah. It was like my mom was like, bring flip flops because she was so afraid I was going to get like planters warts
前酷。发胶明星。对。所以那是它变成一个时髦地方之前。条件很艰苦。对。我妈妈说，带上人字拖，因为她太害怕我会从浴室里
from the shower. Sounds like me. And I was like flip flops because the water, the standing water in the shower was like three inches high. Why would you check into a hotel $60 a night as opposed to like an apartment for, I don't know, $300, $400 a month at that time? Because we didn't even know the city.
染上足底疣了。听起来很像我。我说人字拖是因为水，浴室里积着的水有三英寸高。你为什么会入住一晚60美元的酒店，而不是当时租个一个月，我不知道，300、400美元的公寓呢？因为我们对这座城市一无所知。
We went so blindly, like just like, we're going to go there. We're going to stay in this hotel until we find an apartment. These dirty hippies. Good with anything. Oh, good. Like my cousin George is going to get me a job. Ethan's working at Starbucks.
我们盲目地去了，就像，我们要去那儿。我们要在这个酒店住下来，直到找到公寓。这些肮脏的嬉皮士。什么都能接受。哦，挺好。就像我表哥乔治会给我找工作一样。伊森在星巴克工作。
Like it's all going to happen. Right. It was crazy. And did it have, how fast was it? Did it start happening? No. So you were auditioning for stuff, I would imagine. It didn't start happening for a really long time.
就像一切都会水到渠成一样。对。这太疯狂了。而且有吗，进展有多快？事情开始有进展了吗？没有。所以我想你当时一定在到处试镜。事情过了好久才开始有起色。
I mean, I started, I was auditioning like, you know, I had like off, off, off, off, off, off, off, off, Broadway, you know, that crab like that was like, you can do it if you find 12 people. Yeah. To pay to come see it. Right, right, right. Yeah.
我是说，我开始，我在试镜，你知道的，我有那种外，外，外，外，外，外，外，外百老汇的演出，你知道，那种破烂货，只要你能找到12个人就能演的那种。对，对，对，对。
And like, what, what, what, what, what was the first thing that like gave you some money and, and, and, and used like, okay, I can make a living at this. I no longer have to work the reception desk at the beauty salon. I mean, we started going to Williamstown. Yeah. I probably did like seven summers there, which was pretty life changing.
然后，什么，什么，什么，什么，什么才是第一件给你带来一些钱，并且，并且，并且，让你觉得，好吧，我能靠这个谋生了。我不再需要在美容院当前台了。我是说，我们开始去威廉斯敦。yeah。我在那儿大概呆了七个夏天，这可以说是改变人生经历。
Right. Williamstown, they do a lot of theater there, yeah. Yeah. And then I got that doesn't pay. No, it doesn't pay. In fact, no, it doesn't pay at all. But then I got into Yale and I went to grad school for acting. That also doesn't pay, which does not pay.
对，威廉斯敦，他们在那里做很多戏剧，对。对。然后我得到了那个不给钱的。不，那是不给钱的。事实上，不，那是一点钱都不给。但后来我考上了耶鲁，我去读了表演研究生院。那个也是不给钱的，那个确实不给钱。
And in fact, I put myself when you came out, did you get something that was, I came out with a holding deal. There it is. And I, that's when I got crossing. George was through the holding deal is when they pay you money so you don't audition anywhere else. They, yeah, they basically own you, which is, it's good.
而且事实上，我把自己当成——你出来的时候，你得到了一个什么，我带着一份保留合约出来的。这就对了。然后我，那就是我得到克罗星的时候。乔治是通过保留合约进来的，那是他们付你钱让你不要去别的地方试镜。他们，对，他们基本上拥有了你，这，这挺好的。
Yeah. Well, you know, then it was great. It is. Yeah. Well, especially in a fake old business, you get a guaranteed check. It's, it's nice. So Catherine, you know, I love horror theater horror stories.
对，你知道的，那很好。确实是。对，特别是做这种虚假的老生意，你能得到一张保底支票，挺不错的。所以凯瑟琳，你知道，我喜欢恐怖戏剧的恐怖故事。
And I know these guys love them too, but they'll say they don't. Sorry. Horror. You're saying horror. OK. And so tell these guys the story about some clinking glasses or something or cheersing something. Didn't you have a horror theater story about like in a scene,
我知道这些家伙也很喜欢，但他们会说他们不喜欢。抱歉。恐怖。你刚才说的是恐怖。好的。所以给这些家伙讲讲关于碰杯或者干杯之类的故事吧。你不是有个恐怖戏剧故事吗，比如在某一幕里，
somebody was cheersing now? Didn't you, Catherine, you got something about, there's a cheers story. Didn't you have clink glasses or something funny stuff? Go fuck. You're going to, it's not, you're not going to win it, Sean. They're listening right now. The people making their decisions.
有人在干杯？凯瑟琳，你不是有什么关于干杯的故事吗？难道你没有碰杯或者类似的好玩的事情吗？去你的。你不会赢的，肖恩。他们现在正在听着呢。那些做决定的人。
Sean, you have. It's been narrowed down to five people now. You believe what I do. It's just you against. We'll have fun. OK. We're just jealous that Sean got one. I was in a play.
肖恩，你有。现在已经缩小到五个人了。你相信我做的事。这只是你和……我们会玩得很开心的。好吧。我们只是嫉妒肖恩拿到了一个。我曾经演过一部话剧。
Yeah. Come on, guys. It's the host of the year. I'm sorry. It's bitterness. It hurts. I know. It does.
对。拜托，伙计们。这是年度最佳主持人。对不起。这是痛苦。这很伤人。我懂。确实如此。
OK. It was, I was in a play with, I was in my one and only Broadway play was called Bowing Bowing. Oh, yeah. I remember that. Yeah. It was, do you? Well, I remember not buying, I remember going, nope.
好吧。那是，我演过一部戏，我的第一部也是唯一一部百老汇话剧叫《波音波音》。哦，对。我记得那个。对。你记得？好吧，我记得没买，我记得当时想，不要。
Oh. Yeah, yeah, not buying tickets to it, you know. But promises, promises. Yes, yes. Yes, yes. No, no, no, all jokes aside, I remember when that was yes on Broadway. So that was your first, that was your one and only.
哦。对，对，没买票去看，你知道的。但是《甜心妙女郎》。是的，是的。是的，是的。不，不，不，抛开玩笑不谈，我记得那是百老汇的演出。所以那是你的第一部，那是你唯一的一部。
That was a big hit. My first and only, but the cast was like crazy. It was Mark Rylandson, Whitford, and Miriam McCormick, and it was Christine Baransky. It was a great experience, and it was like a farce. Mark Matthew Ward constructed it. It was like a big old farce, and I think that's what we mean. Like, we had to cheers each other every night,
那是个大热门。我的第一部也是唯一一部，但演员阵容简直疯狂。有马克·里朗斯、布莱德利·惠特福德、玛丽安·麦考密克，还有克里斯蒂娜·巴兰斯基。这是一次很棒的体验，就像是一部闹剧。马克·马修·沃德构建的。这就像是一部老派的大闹剧，我想这就是我们的意思。比如，我们每晚都必须互相干杯，
and so I just always did, like, there were so many times I did it with such force, like poor, like, fucking Mark would be so annoyed at me. And then I had to do this thing where I flashed him every night. But so from the audience's perspective, they just saw, like, the towel, and they just saw his reaction. But then we all wanted to just, to make Mark break, because he was such an easy laugh.
所以我总是这样做，有很多次我用力过猛，像可怜的、他妈的马克会对我感到非常恼火。然后我必须做一件事，就是每晚向他裸露身体。所以从观众的角度来看，他们只能看到毛巾，然后只能看到他的反应。但后来我们都只想让马克笑场，因为他太容易笑场了。
No, like, he's such an easy laugh. It was hilarious. So, like, one night I would just, like, take Bradley Whitford's headshot, and I cut it into a triangle, and I just taped it down there. I was like, just, we would just do this stupidest crap to try to make him laugh. And then he would just, like, lean into it.
不，我是说，他太容易笑场了。这太搞笑了。所以，比如有一天晚上我就会拿一张布莱德利·惠特福德的头像，把它剪成三角形，然后贴在那下面。我心想，就是，我们只会做最蠢的恶作剧来试图逗笑他。然后他就会顺着演下去。
So, like, our stage manager would be like, oh, okay, like, it would, the show, the duration time would be, like, would be, like, 20 minutes longer. Screwing around time. I mean, it would be, like, depending on how the audience was, it would just, it was hilarious.
所以，我们的舞台经理就会说，哦，好吧，比如，演出，持续时间会，比如，会延长20分钟。胡闹的时间。我是说，这取决于观众的反应，这简直太搞笑了。
All Mark. But he's, like, you know, he's a shaman, I think. I think he's so gifted. Actor's actor. An actor's actor. So, this is not a great question and a tough one, I'll bet you, but your star is rising with the bullet. And I'm sure that all, you know,
全是马克的功劳。但他，你知道的，我认为他是个萨满。我觉得他太有天赋了。演员中的演员。演员中的演员。所以，这不是一个好问题，而且很难，我敢打赌，但你的明星运势正扶摇直上。我敢肯定所有，你知道的，
they want you to continue to be the funniest thing on screen and steal all the scenes and stuff, but then you're also getting these parts, probably, that are maybe even the lead on something where it's not always maybe that funny, and are you battling sort of the decision between, like, do I continue to take these parts where I can really score,
他们希望你继续成为银幕上最搞笑的人，抢尽所有的戏份之类的，但接着你也接到了一些角色，可能甚至是某部作品的主角，那里面可能并不总是那么搞笑，你是不是在艰难地权衡这样一种决定：我是继续接那些我能大显身手的角色，
or do I take these larger parts that I less score, but I'm in more of it? And, like, how do you, are you strategizing about your future, or what kind of stuff you want to do? I mean, I don't know. This is why I don't get nominated for fucking a husband. Oh, stop it! But I mean, I've always, like...
还是接那些我发挥空间较小但戏份更多的大角色？而且，你会不会为自己的未来做战略规划，或者你想做什么样的角色？我是说，我不知道。这就是为什么我没有因为他妈的丈夫而被提名。哦，得了吧！但我的意思是，我一直……
Go ahead. Did I say any of that out loud? You guys. After I was done with the question, did you hear me talking at all? Unfortunately, the question was out loud. That's an awesome question. I mean, I, I like, I mean, I feel like
说吧。我刚才把那些话大声说出来了吗？你们这些家伙。在我问完问题之后，你们听到我说话了吗？不幸的是，这个问题是大声问出来的。那是个很棒的问题。我是说，我，我喜欢，我是说，我觉得
I've been able to do some stuff that kind of lands in the middle of all of it. So that's the kind of stuff that I'm the most attracted to anyway. So if it happens to be a lead, it happens to be a lead, but it also can be supporting. You know, Katherine, you're in this sort of elite group of actors, and I put you in there, a lot of,
我能够做一些刚好介于两者中间的事情。所以这正是我最感兴趣的事情。所以如果它碰巧是个主角，那就是个主角，但它也可以是配角。你知道的，凯瑟琳，你属于那种精英演员群体，我把你也归入其中，很多人，
and it's not that big of people. You're always, always, always good, no matter what the thing is. In every single thing you do. You're like John Goodman in that way. You're like, it's a very small group. Oh my God, that is the most flattering comparison. Yeah, like Meryl Streep, like all those people.
而且人数并不多。你总是，总是，总是演得很好，无论演什么。在你做的每一件事里。你就像那里的约翰·古德曼一样。你就像，这是一个非常小的群体。哦，天哪，这是最恭维的比较了。是的，就像梅丽尔·斯特里普，就像所有这些人。
But no, you're always good. And you know, you're not gonna phone it in like a Bateman or a Hayes. You're gonna deliver every time, you know? No, you're gonna phone it in like a Narnette. So the, just a little bit more about the career stuff because I think you're such a fascinating actress. And I think you, do you feel now
但真的，你总是演得很好。而且你知道的，你不会像贝特曼或海斯那样敷衍了事。你每次都能不负众望，你知道的？不，你会像纳内特那样敷衍了事。所以，再多聊一点关于职业的事情，因为我觉得你是一个如此迷人的演员。而且我觉得你，你现在觉得
that you're finally getting the attention you deserve? Sure, you're always working, but now you're kind of more in the spotlight than ever. It feels like from my perspective, from someone who, you know, who watches your work and admires you, it just seems like finally, like I've been a life fan, but it feels like finally the press is catching up to you.
你终于得到了应有的关注吗？当然，你一直在工作，但现在你比以往任何时候都更处于聚光灯下。从我的角度来看，从一个，你知道的，看你的作品并崇拜你的人的角度来看，感觉就像终于，虽然我一直是你的终极粉丝，但感觉终于媒体开始注意到你了。
Do you feel that as well? I mean, WandaVision was not so. Like that was crazy. I've never experienced anything like that. So that was boggers. And it was certainly, it's interesting because it was certainly not the thing that I thought would have been the thing.
你也有这种感觉吗？我是说，《旺达幻视》可不是这样的。那太疯狂了。我从来没有经历过那样的事情。所以那真是难以置信。而且这当然，这很有趣，因为它绝对不是我认为会带来这种影响的作品。
You know, you just never fricking know. Yeah, it's massive. But it seems like people are finally taking notice in the best way. And I don't know, from my perspective, at least. Do you have something when you're working, do you have a big peeve about the process or the way that things are getting made
你知道，你永远他妈的猜不到。对，它太火了。但看起来人们终于以最好的方式注意到了这一点。我不知道，至少从我的角度来看是这样。你在工作的时候，对拍戏流程或者制作方式有没有什么特别看不顺眼的地方？
that you just don't adhere to? That you're just like, you know what? That really doesn't work for me. I mean, I do, like I guess it would be like in the hair and makeup trailer when someone comes in and is doing like a voice memo really loudly that everyone else has to shut up for. It's always really fricking annoying.
就是那种你根本无法认同的做法？你就会想：你知道吗？这对我真的不管用。我是说，有的，我想大概就是在发型和化妆间里，当有人进来，然后非常大声地发语音备忘录，让其他人不得不闭嘴的时候。这总是他妈的真的很烦人。
Or just walking in on a face time. Yeah, it's just kind of like, guys, you can step outside. Like now the whole trailer has to be kind of quiet. It's always a little, and also just pick up your clothes. Like, and maybe that comes from the theater, but I'm always like, hang your fricking costumes up. Like, it's not that big of a deal. I agree with that.
或者直接开着FaceTime走进来。对，这就有点像，各位，你们可以出去打。现在整个化妆间都得保持安静。这总是有点，还有就是把你的衣服收好。也许这是因为我出身戏剧界，但我总是觉得：把你们他妈的戏服挂起来。这又不是什么大不了的事。我同意这一点。
Well, hang on. Are you sharing a trailer with somebody? Do you need a better representation? I don't know. We always share trailers. I mean, it's a different level. Aline, negotiate you at least a triple banger or something? Yeah, but our triple bangers are just,
等等。你在跟别人共用一个化妆间吗？你需要更好的经纪人吗？我不知道。我们总是共用化妆间。我是说，这是另一个级别的待遇。艾琳，没帮你至少谈下一个三联式化妆间什么的吗？对，但我们的三联式化妆间只是，
it's just one long car. And then we're all just kind of bouncing around. That was the other title of our podcast was triple banger. Triple banger. It would have been good. Don't you think in general, though, face times need to happen when you're alone?
它只是一辆长车。然后我们所有人都在里面挤来挤去。我们的播客另一个名字叫“三联式化妆间”。三联式化妆间。那倒挺不错的。你不觉得一般来说，FaceTime应该在你独处时打吗？
You can't, if you're in a group of people, you cannot use face time, right? Isn't that imposing on other people's space? Because I also feel like, naturally, the human voice gets louder when we're on face time. Right. And it's just like a little bit performative. And then when other people are around,
如果你在一群人中间，你不能用FaceTime，对吧？这不是在侵犯别人的空间吗？因为我也觉得，很自然地，当我们用FaceTime时，人类的声音会变大。对。而且这有点像是在表演。然后当有其他人周围时，
yeah, I'm with you. Yeah, I don't want to be a part of your conversation. You probably are not with me on this, but I hate phones on sets. Yeah, well, of course. I do, too. Who likes it? Well, to sort of fill the gaps in between
是的，我同意你的看法。对，我不想参与你的对话。你可能不会同意我的看法，但我讨厌片场出现手机。对，好吧，当然。我也讨厌。谁会喜欢呢？为了填补你工作和不工作之间的空白，
when you're working and not working? You should not, because I think it takes you out of it. And I used to try to institute a rule and said, no. Because now you look around, and if everybody's there, you look at everybody in every department is on there. Where's the small talk? Where's everybody hanging out together? Like, we got to be making whatever, ensemble.
你不应该这样做，因为我认为这会让你分心。我以前曾试图制定一条规则，说：不准用。因为现在你环顾四周，如果每个人都在那儿，你看每个部门的每个人都在玩手机。闲聊去哪了？大家一起闲逛去哪了？我们得创造点什么，比如剧团感。
Either go back to your trailer or just hang out. It feels like, it bumps me out sometimes. I agree. But, Catherine, if there was a no phone rule on set, do you think that you'd be great about generating, maintaining all of that small talk? Are you good at small talk? Are you a sociable person?
要么回你的化妆间，要么就四处转转。这有时让我感到沮丧。我同意。但是，凯瑟琳，如果片场有一条禁手机规则，你觉得你能很好地引发并维持所有这些闲聊吗？你擅长闲聊吗？你是一个善于社交的人吗？
I am good at leaving when I need to and coming back when I need to. Like, I go to my trailer for lunch and recharge. Yeah. Do you nap at lunch, ever? Do you ever nap? Really good at a power nap. Same.
我擅长在需要离开时离开，在需要回来时回来。比如，我去化妆间吃午饭并充电。对。你午饭时会小睡吗？你从来不小睡吗？我非常擅长快速小睡。我也是。
We just did it before you came on. Will, didn't Barry Sonofil teach you how to nap on set? Yeah, he told me one day after coming back from lunch, he was like, now you gotta nap, didn't you? I go, honey, and he goes, I can tell by your face is buffing. And he goes, you got a nap sitting up. And I was like, thanks a lot.
我们在你上节目之前刚小睡过。威尔，难道巴里·索南菲尔德没有教过你在片场怎么小睡吗？对，有一天他吃完午饭回来对我说：现在你得小睡了，不是吗？我说：亲爱的，他说：我从你浮肿的脸上就能看出来。然后他说：你得坐着小睡。我说：多谢了。
Like, I mean, while he's like, all right, let's start shooting. I'm like, I'm not gonna shoot with this face. Are you crazy? Naps sitting up like a cow. Let's do my angle last. Anyway, I do, I nap sitting up. And we will be right back.
就像，当他说：好吧，我们开始拍吧。我就想：我才不要带着这副尊容拍戏呢。你疯了吗？像头奶牛一样坐着小睡。把我的角度留到最后拍吧。不管怎样，我确实坐着小睡。我们马上回来。
All right, back to the show. Katherine, other than your beautiful family, what, how do you balance life from work? You have like hobbies and stuff like that. Hmm. Yeah. Sean, did you just give up? Mm-hmm, yep.
好的，回到节目中。凯瑟琳，除了你美丽的家人，你如何平衡生活与工作？你有什么爱好之类的东西吗？嗯。是的。肖恩，你这就放弃了？嗯哼，是的。
You know why? You know why? Cause I'm sweating my balls off. Are you? Hi, honey, it's hot in there. Oh my God, it's so hot. And Scotty's not in here. And I don't know how to change this.
你知道为什么吗？你知道为什么吗？因为我都快热死了。是吗？嗨，亲爱的，里面好热啊。哦，天哪，太热了。而且斯科蒂不在这里。我不知道怎么调这个。
Oh, you're in New York, right? Three steps. You're in New York. Don't go and change it, don't go and change it. You have to suffer. Get up and change the thermos. This is incredible. Okay, okay, while he's gone.
哦，你在纽约，对吧？三步。你在纽约。别去调它，别去调它。你必须受着。起来调一下恒温器。这太不可思议了。好吧，好吧，趁他不在。
Do you have any hobbies? While he's gone. No, he's putting a bad God down. Sean, go do it, go adjust it. Sean, go adjust it. I just did it. What was it at? What was the thermos at at?
你有什么爱好吗？趁他不在。不，他在放低上帝。肖恩，去弄一下，去调一下。肖恩，去调一下。我刚刚调过了。刚才调到多少度？
75. 75? What do you go, a monster? I'm like drenched. Sweating my balls off. Hey, do you have any hobbies? You like it cold over there, Katherine? Yeah, we keep it a little chilly over here.
75度。75度？你当自己是怪物吗？我都湿透了。快热死了。嘿，你有什么爱好吗？你喜欢那边冷一点，凯瑟琳？对，我们这边保持得有点凉快。
Not gonna lie. I love it. Yeah. Sean, let's get back to your hobby question. Yeah, so let me ask you a different way. So Katherine, you know, other than your beautiful family, how do you fill the time in between gigs because I'm always looking for great ideas.
实话实说。我喜欢。对。肖恩，让我们回到你的爱好问题上。对，那我换个方式问你。所以凯瑟琳，你知道，除了你美丽的家人，你在两个工作间隙是如何消磨时间的，因为我一直在寻找好主意。
Okay, thanks, Sean. Katherine. Thanks, Sean. Katherine. I, I mean, listen, between gigs, it is mothering an existential crisis until the next gig. Yeah, all right. Right.
好的，谢谢，肖恩。凯瑟琳。谢谢，肖恩。凯瑟琳。我，我的意思是，听着，在两个工作间隙，这简直就是当母亲加上存在主义危机，直到下一个工作到来。对，好吧。对。
Katherine, I'm sorry about this. You know, it's just, if we didn't like you and know you so well, we'd actually have a decent interview here, but we don't want to do a decent interview. We want to fuck around with our panel. We just want to fuck around. Let's just fuck around, guys.
凯瑟琳，真对不起。你知道的，如果我们不喜欢你，对你不是这么了解，我们今天就会做一场像样的采访了，但我们不想做像样的采访。我们只想和我们的嘉宾瞎胡闹。我们只想瞎胡闹。我们瞎胡闹吧，伙计们。
It's fine. It's a rainy Monday. I love you. I'm so grateful that Sean, you asked me to do it. Well, listen, Katherine, talk. I want to know a bit. Let's get to five questions. I think we're at about three questions.
没关系。这是一个下雨的星期一。我爱你。我非常感谢肖恩你邀请我来。好吧，听着，凯瑟琳，聊聊。我想了解一点。我们进入五个问题吧。我觉得我们大概聊了三个问题。
Let's get two more good quality questions. Here's what I want to know. Here's what I want to know about you. I want to know about your sensibility. What is your favorite film of all time? You have like a film or like it's sort of an area that you like that you go- A touchstone.
让我们再来两个高质量的问题。这是我想知道的。这是关于你的sensibility（审美品味）我想知道的。你心目中历来最喜欢的电影是什么？你有一部电影，或者说某种你喜欢的类型，那种你会去——一块试金石。
Yeah. What would you say it would be? I would say- And don't be cool. And don't be cool and don't be like- Dust Boots. You know, like, yeah. By the way, Dust Boots is a great film.
对。你觉得会是什么？我会说——别装酷。别装酷，也别说什么——《油脂靴》。你知道的，就像，顺便说一句，《油脂靴》是一部伟大的电影。
Dust Boots is a great movie, but also intense. I mean, I would say, I mean, listen, Woman of the Influence is incredible movie, but I also love E.T. Great. I love E.T. That's a great answer. A little bit of the both.
《油脂靴》是一部伟大的电影，但也充满激情。我的意思是，我会说，听着，《受影响的女人》是一部不可思议的电影，但我也爱《E.T.》。太棒了。我爱《E.T.》。这是一个很好的回答。两者兼顾。
That's a great answer. And when you were a kid, who would you watch movies and TV and go, God, I'd kill to have her career. I'd kill me just like her. Oh, Terry Gar. Nice pause. There you go. I just watched Tootsie last night.
那是一个很好的回答。当你还是个孩子的时候，你看电影和电视时会想：天哪，我做梦都想拥有她的事业。我做梦都想变得像她一样。哦，特瑞·加尔。漂亮的停顿。这就对了。我昨晚刚看了《窈窕淑男》。
By the way, you've nailed it. But you've nailed it. Yeah, you have to. You know that I have independent of ever knowing that you said that. I've referenced you as Terry Gar a thousand times. Is that true? Are you serious?
顺便说一句，你猜对了。但你真的说准了。是的，你必须这样。你知道我在从不知道你说过这话之前。我已经把你看作特瑞·加尔一千次了。真的吗？你是认真的吗？
On my kid's life, both of them. Yep. That's crazy. Quick to put stuff on your kid's life. I've noticed that. Because you said it a few times. And Captain. Wait, Sean, you just watched Tootsie recently.
拿我孩子的生活发誓，两个都是。是的。太疯狂了。发誓拿孩子的生活赌咒可真快。我注意到了。因为你已经说过好几次了。还有，凯瑟琳。等等，肖恩，你最近刚看了《窈窕淑男》。
I just watched Tootsie last night. And did it hold on? Did it hold on? Oh my God, it's one of the best movies of all time. It's like one of the best movies. It's flawless. It's a perfect movie. But getting back to my earlier dumb question,
我昨晚刚看《窈窕淑男》。那它经得起时间的考验吗？经得起考验吗？哦，天哪，这是有史以来最好的电影之一。这简直是最好的电影之一。它无可挑剔。这是一部完美的电影。但回到我刚才那个愚蠢的问题，
that's, now, Terry Gar didn't really have a lot of lead roles in her life, did she? No, but again. Do you want that, I guess, is my question. Yes, of course. I also love like, Gina Rowland's, forget it. Forget it. Are there any roles that you get offered?
那个，现在，特瑞·加尔在她的一生中其实并没有很多主角戏，对吧？没有，但话说回来。我想这也是我的问题，你想要那种吗？是的，当然。我也喜欢像吉娜·罗兰兹，算了。算了。有没有什么角色是你会被邀请出演的？
And because of their, maybe they lean towards more obvious, they lean towards the sexuality of a woman. And you're just like, God, I don't want to do those things. Is there stuff you turn down right away? No. I think I've done it all. I mean, I've definitely done, I've been afforded in this weird chapter like post-kids.
并且因为它们，也许它们更倾向于显而易见的东西，它们倾向于展现女性的性感。而你就会想：天哪，我才不想做那些事。有没有什么角色你是会立刻拒绝的？没有。我想我都演过了。我是说，我绝对演过，在有了孩子之后的这个奇怪的阶段，我被赋予了这种特权。
I've been able to do some juicy, tell some juicy stories that have not been just like, there's this movie I did called Private Life, which I'm like crazy, super proud of. It's me and Giamatti. Yeah, Paul Giamatti, what was that like? How was he? He was great.
我能够讲述一些多汁的故事，而不仅仅是——我拍过一部叫《私生活》的电影，我对此超级、超级骄傲。里面有我和吉亚玛提。是的，保罗·吉亚玛提，那感觉怎么样？他怎么样？他太棒了。
I love him. I think my favorite experience, and it's about a couple that's like, it's Tamara Jenkins. And it's a couple that's going through like their, it doesn't sound funny, but it's funny. The couple going through their IVF journey. But it's like really funny. And it's also horribly heartbreaking.
我爱他。我觉得我最喜欢的经历，而且它是关于一对夫妇的，这是塔玛拉·詹金斯的电影。这是一对正在经历他们的——这听起来可能不好笑，但它很好笑。一对正在经历试管婴儿历程的夫妇。但它真的很好笑。而且也极其心碎。
Right. And like, you know, I love Dick was something that was like a different, like a whole different like. Keep it to the movies. Keep it to the movies you like. Okay, we're not going into general likes. We're not going to go into general likes. Just keep it to the movies, Catherine.
对。而且，你知道的，我喜欢《迪克》（I Love Dick），那是另一种，完全不同的。说回电影。说回你喜欢的电影。好吧，我们不谈一般的喜好。我们不谈一般的喜好。只谈电影，凯瑟琳。
No, you don't. Jesus Christ. My poor children. But like, so yeah, I mean, of course I'm attracted to like the, that I, there's nothing that I'm like, if it's an interesting story and whatever. How are you managing all of this work though with you, I know you love your husband and your kids too.
不，你没有。天哪。我可怜的孩子们。不过，是的，我是说，当然，我会被——吸引，如果没有什么是让我觉得——如果它是一个有趣的故事，管它呢。不过，你又是如何平衡这一切工作的呢？我知道你也爱你的丈夫和孩子们。
Like, but you say they went to Serbia with you. They did not go to Serbia. They went to Greece. Then they, then I was gone for a little bit. And then I came home and I was like, nothing, I'm here. I mean, you know how, I mean, you know how it is. It's like you're gone for a chunk. Right.
但你说他们跟你去了塞尔维亚。他们没有去塞尔维亚。他们去了希腊。然后他们，然后我离开了一会儿。然后我回到家说：没事，我在这儿。我是说，你知道的，我是说，你知道那是怎么回事。就像你离开了一段时间。对。
But the ratio like, I don't think I've, have you guys declared the ratio that you're going to spend away from home versus at home? I mean, I guess we can't really, right? You just kind of kind of go from job to job. Yeah. But you know what sucks? It's just that they need you the more the older they get.
但这个比例，我觉得，你们有没有确定过在外面陪伴的时间与在家陪伴的时间的比例？我是说，我想我们真的没法确定，对吧？你只能从一个工作接着下一个工作。对。但你知道最糟糕的是什么吗？就是随着他们长大，他们反而更需要你。
I know it. They need you around. And yet the older they get, the harder it is for them to travel with you because they're involved with their social continuity and their educational, you know, consistency and all of that stuff. Yeah.
我懂。他们需要你在身边。然而他们越长大，他们跟你一起旅行就越难，因为他们有他们的社交圈延续性、教育（稳定性），你知道的，所有这些乱七八糟的事情。对。
So it's like really big, big, everyone is a big decision now for sure. Cause of all that stuff. What about dream role? Is there something that you've always wanted to play and you just haven't got a chance yet? Or are you like, I want to play this. I guess I'm going to have to write it for myself
所以现在这真的是一个重大决定，对每个人来说都是个重大决定，因为所有这些事情。关于梦想中的角色呢？有没有什么你一直想演却还没机会演的角色？或者你会觉得：我想演这个。我想我得为自己写一个了，
cause it'll never be offered to me, anything like that. I mean, I guess like, you know, I guess there's just a woman. Nancy Reagan. Nancy Reagan. Yeah. Nancy Reagan. And everyone's lest.
因为这永远不会有人找我演，诸如此类的？我是说，我想，你知道，我想大概就是一个女人。南希·里根。南希·里根。对。南希·里根。每个人都……
Yeah. Yeah, yeah. Very complex. I'm going to be allowed to, but I really would love to play Nancy Reagan. There we go. You know, but I think I, you know, like any, a woman like just as she's aging,
对。对，对，非常复杂。我会不会被允许，但我真的很想演南希·里根。这就对了。你知道的，但我想我，你知道，就像任何一个，一个女人在老去的过程中，
like in the juicy complexity of it is to be a person in a woman's body that's getting older and older and older. Like, I, you know, if I could continue to have those parts to show, like all the nooks and crannies of. Right. Yeah. Because as we age, we get to play more interesting characters
就像在它多汁的复杂性中，作为一个身体日渐衰老的女人去成为一个人。如果我能继续接到那些角色去展现，比如所有的角角落落。对。对。因为随着我们变老，我们可以扮演更有趣的角色，
where some actors think, Oh God, as I get older, all the good parts are gone or they're not going to hire me as much cause I'm getting older. Well, it's actually where all the good parts are. That's what I have found in my career. Oddly is the more interesting my life has been post 40, which is like, I really think
虽然有些演员会想：哦，天哪，当我老了，所有好角色都没了，或者他们不会因为我变老而雇佣我那么多。好吧，这其实正是所有好角色所在的地方。这就是我在我的职业生涯中发现的。奇怪的是，我40岁之后的生活变得更有趣了，就像，我真的觉得
I want to tell this young actors that are panicked. Like you just never fricking know, like all the society was telling me, like, once you have kids, you're, you're done. Like as a, especially as a woman, like you're done. Right. But that's old thinking though. That doesn't exist.
我想告诉那些恐慌的年轻演员们：你永远他妈的猜不到，就像所有的社会都在告诉我，一旦有了孩子，你就完了。作为一个，特别是作为一个女性，你就像完蛋了一样。对。但这已经是老旧的想法了。那种情况已经不存在了。
That's old thinking. You know, I used to have an acting teacher who used to say he hated child actors. He's like, what do they have to draw on? They have no experience. These people, they're born, they have no, and it's the same thing with young, a lot of young character.
那是老旧的想法。你知道，我以前有个表演老师，他说他讨厌童星。他说：他们有什么人生阅历可资借鉴？他们毫无经验。这些人，他们刚出生，什么都没有。很多年轻的特型演员也是这样。
Who gives a shit? You know what I mean? Now, of course that's saying that as a guy who's getting older was a middle-aged guy who still plays 30, but like, you know, that that's, that's my, you know, barely. And, you know, who's an icon for the young people. But, you know, and I could go on and on and on.
谁他妈在乎？你知道我的意思吗？当然，作为一个正在变老的男人，作为一个仍然在演30多岁的中年男人，我这么说——但是，你知道，那是，那是我的，你知道，勉强算吧。而且，你知道的，谁又是年轻人的偶像呢？但是，你知道，我可以滔滔不绝地说个没完。
No, you don't have to. We got it. What do you think the youngest Will Arnett could play, Catherine? Be honest and be kind. No, you don't have to be kind. Be honest. I mean, let's really be honest here.
不，你不用。我们明白了。凯瑟琳，你觉得威尔·阿奈特最年轻能演几岁？说实话，而且要善良。不，你不用善良。说实话。我是说，让我们真正诚实一点。
What is he, I'll start. We'll go around. We'll be my turn and then we'll go for each of us. No, we're not going to start with you. In fact, I don't even think you get to respond to this. I would honestly say that I could honestly cast you as a 32 year old guy. I could, yeah, yeah, yeah.
他几岁，我先来。我们轮流来。先轮到我，然后我们每个人都来。不，我们不从你开始。事实上，我觉得你甚至不能回答这个问题。我老实说，我真的可以把你当作一个32岁的家伙来选角。我可以，对，对，对。
Yeah, I was going to say that. I was going to, I was to be totally honest. I was going to say 36. Yeah. Now, not, I don't, I just want to be honest. Cause we were talking about that before. This is the greatest day of my life. I would say all four of us could play in our 30s.
对，我正要这么说。我本来要，说实话。我本来要说36岁。现在，不是，我不想，我只是想说实话。因为我们之前讨论过这个。这是我生命中最棒的一天。我会说我们四个人都可以演30多岁的人。
Could we not? Are we nuts? Are we nuts? Listen, I've, I've seen 50 year old people. And I don't, I don't, I, they look, I'd look a lot older than you will. Thank you. Do you know what's interesting?
难道不是吗？我们疯了吗？我们疯了吗？听着，我，我见过50岁的人。我不觉得，我不觉得，他们看起来，我看起来比威尔老得多。谢谢。你知道有趣的是什么吗？
Remember the show, The Golden Girls? Yeah. They were all, weren't they all, I'm going to get this wrong. God bless. Weren't they all in their fifties, but we were made to believe they were older than that? Or were they in their forties even maybe?
还记得那个节目《黄金女郎》吗？对。她们全都是，难道她们不都是——我要说错了。上帝保佑。难道她们不都在50多岁，但我们却被灌输她们比那还要老的观念吗？或者她们甚至可能才40多岁？
Come on. I wish there was a way we could find out information quickly. Guys, I've got a computer over here. You want to hold on a second? I want to find that out, The Golden. Hey, Catherine, let me ask you, let me, let me ask you the last great question.
拜托。我希望有什么方法能让我们快速查到信息。伙计们，我这里有一台电脑。你们想等一下吗？我想查查那个，《黄金》。嘿，凯瑟琳，让我问你，让我，让我问你最后一个很棒的问题。
Have you done an interview worse than this? They're in their fifties. Have you ever been interviewed by three dumber, less prepared? I have never done an interview that has been more entertaining and charming. None less interesting. And just vague. Yeah.
你做过比这更烂的采访吗？她们五十多岁。你有没有被三个更愚蠢、准备更不充分的人采访过？我从来没有做过比这更有趣、更有魅力的采访了。没有比这更无聊的了。而且还含糊不清。对。
Vague. And just vague. That's what we're going to call this. Completely vague. Yeah. That's what it is. It's just charming as hell. There's no beginning.
含糊不清。这就是我们要给这期节目起的名字。完全含糊不清。对。就是这样。简直迷人得要命。没有开头。
There's no middle. There's no end. Which I love. It's kind of like life. Yeah. But this was just a slice of life. Yeah. Big finish, Sean.
没有中间。没有结尾。我很喜欢这样。这有点像生活。对。但这只是生活的一个切片。对。精彩的收尾，肖恩。
Big finish. What's your best question on the list? No, I don't need any more questions because she's going to come visit me in my apartment in New York City. Is that true? And I'm going to ask her, I'm going to make her. And I'm going to ask her questions without these two knobs.
精彩的收尾。你单子上的最佳问题是什么？不，我不需要更多问题了，因为她要来我在纽约市的公寓拜访我。真的吗？我要问她，我要让她……我要抛开这两个笨蛋直接问她问题。
We'll go to, maybe we'll go to names and faces. Well, but what about for Tracy? One last good one for Tracy. One last good one for Tracy. She's very disappointed in this interview. And she really wants to end it. Tracy, don't be disappointed, Tracy. It's a lot of fun.
我们可以去，也许我们可以去“名字与面孔”。好吧，那特蕾西呢？给特蕾西留一个好的问题。给特蕾西留一个好的问题。她对这次采访非常失望。她真的很想结束它。特蕾西，别失望，特蕾西。这很有趣。
Give her one more, Sean. We're having a lot of fun. It was a rainy, cozy, bad day. Here's one that I love. Here's one that I ask often because I am always interested. Kids want to do what mom does or no. No. Or dad.
再给她一个，肖恩。我们玩得很开心。这是一个下雨天，很温馨，糟糕的一天。这里有一个我很喜欢的。这是我经常问的一个问题，因为我一直很感兴趣。孩子们想做妈妈做的事吗？不。还是爸爸做的事？
Oh, actually, my son. Oh my God, you guys, I almost just burped right in the microphone. You almost threw up on the mic. I almost made myself laugh when the paper was over it at the very beginning because I was like, what if I just had cut the loudest part while you guys were just doing it? If you had laughed with your tiny little snort,
哦，事实上，我儿子。哦，天哪，你们这些家伙，我刚才差点就在麦克风前打嗝了。你差点在麦克风前吐出来。一开始纸盖在上面的时候，我差点把自己逗笑了，因为我想：如果我在你们正录的时候打个最响的嗝会怎么样？如果你用你那小小的呼噜声笑出来，
I would have known exactly who it is. Okay, there it is. My son wants to, like, as of right now, he's really in a film. He's in a film class. He's like, really into it. It's a lot of psychological horror going on. Yeah, uh-oh.
我就会一眼认出那是谁了。好吧，就是这样。我儿子想，就目前而言，他对电影很感兴趣。他在上电影课。他真的对它很入迷。里面有很多心理恐怖元素。对，哦哦。
Can I ask you a question? And this is gonna seem somewhat serious. What drew you to the cinema? Just to finish this off. Catherine, thank you for your time today. Sorry, somebody needs to be. Sean, Sean. No, that's it.
我能问你一个问题吗？这看起来会有点严肃。是什么把你吸引到电影院去的？就为了给这期节目画个句号。凯瑟琳，谢谢你今天抽出时间。抱歉，总得有人来。肖恩，肖恩。不，就这样吧。
So, Catherine, listen. You guys, I just, I don't want to think ahead, but I feel like this is your submission for next years. Absolutely. The podcast was. This is gonna get Will and I in the conversation. We're gonna have more of the conversation. This is gonna be the submission.
所以，凯瑟琳，听着。你们这些家伙，我只是，我不想提前考虑，但我觉得这是你们明年的参选作品。绝对是。这个播客。这会让威尔和我进入讨论区。我们会聊得更多。这将是参选作品。
Thank you for the time in your garage that you gave us. Hopefully they let you back in the house. Get back to framing more posters. Sure. I got that. Sorry, what is the turnaround on a poster? Like, it's just a regular poster size. If I bring it in.
谢谢你送给我们你在车库里的时间。希望他们能让你再回屋里去。回去给更多海报装裱吧。当然。我懂那个。抱歉，装裱一张海报要多久？比如，就是普通海报的尺寸。如果我拿过来的话。
If I get it in the mail. It's quick. Okay, because if I do a curbside, if I do a curbside drop-off in the morning, can I get the same day? Can I get the same day? Really? Three hours.
如果我寄到信箱里。这很快。好吧，因为如果我做路边取货，如果我早上做路边投递，我能当天拿到吗？我能当天拿到吗？真的吗？三个小时。
Plastic or glass? Wow. It doesn't matter? I prefer plastic. Sure. You got it. I got it. It's better for the environment.
塑料的还是玻璃的？哇。没关系吗？我更喜欢塑料的。当然。给你。我拿到了。这对环境更好。
It's not taking a little tacky. Catherine. Catherine, I can't do another hour. I know our audience couldn't, but I could. I know. I love you guys so much. Thank you so much. Thank you so much.
这听起来不怎么有点俗气吗？凯瑟琳。凯瑟琳，我没法再聊一个小时了。我知道我们的听众受不了，但我可以。我知道。我太爱你们了。非常感谢。非常感谢。
There was nothing about this hour that I didn't love. Other than you can't get it back. You're a mega talent. You are a mega talent and we worship you. Worship back. Thank you so much for all of this. Mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah. Okay.
这一个小时里没有哪怕一秒钟是我不喜欢的。除了你回不到过去。你是个超级天才。你是个超级天才，我们崇拜你。回敬崇拜。非常感谢这一切。么么哒，么么哒，么么哒，么么哒，么么哒。好了。
Bye, sweetie. Robin Bennett, do I stay on? Flip it. You slam your laptop closed. Bye. I'm finding you all. Bye, Catherine. Love you.
再见，亲爱的。罗宾·贝内特，我还要留在线上吗？切掉。你“啪”地合上了笔记本电脑。再见。我要去找你们所有人。再见，凯瑟琳。爱你们。
Bye. You know what? If you're a fan of the show, if you listen to the show and then you come on the podcast, feel free at the end of the interview to just slam your laptop shut. Because we will have new fan respect for you. Yeah. That's the move.
再见。你知道吗？如果你是节目的粉丝，如果你听了这个节目，然后来上这个播客，采访结束时尽管把笔记本电脑“啪”地合上。因为我们会对你产生一种全新的粉丝敬意。对。这才是帅气之举。
It's the mic drop. Just slam it shut. But what if you're on a desktop? You walk away. You just gotta walk away. Just give up and cut the power to your house. Stick your gun back on your camera. Go outside the bed and just cut the power.
这就是麦克风落地。直接把它合上。但如果你用的是台式电脑呢？你走开。你只能走开。直接放弃并切断你家里的电源。把你的枪重新贴回摄像头上。去床外面，直接切断电源。
Guys, but I have to. Sean, listen, I think that might have been one of our worst interviews. Yes. Because we just wouldn't get on track. I was trying. And I gotta blame you for that. No, no, I was trying.
伙计们，但我必须这么做。肖恩，听着，我觉得这可能是我们最糟糕的一次采访之一。是的。因为我们根本没法按正轨进行。我在努力。我得为此怪你。不，不，我在努力。
You're guest. You gotta keep us on the list. Was it our fault? You feel like it was our fault. No, no, a little bit. But listen, I think that it was also, I think it was a Monday matinee. We were all a little giddy,
你是嘉宾。你得让我们留在清单上。是我们的错吗？你觉得这是我们的错。不，不，有一点点。但听着，我觉得这也是，我觉得这是一场周一的日场秀。我们都有点轻飘飘的，
plus then you get the fourth giddiest person on the planet. I know. So we all had a really good time. It was probably not our, not definitely not our worst. It was our probably our most silliest, which is more fun than I thought. Let me tell you, this is what it's like working with her. Have you guys worked with her yet?
再加上你是这个星球上第四轻飘飘的人。我知道。所以我们都玩得很开心。这可能不是我们的，绝对不是最糟的一次。这可能是我们最傻气的一次，但比我想象的更有趣。我跟你说，跟她工作就是这样的。你们跟她合作过吗？
No, I have not had the pleasure. You just can't get anything done because it's just too much fun hanging out with her. You don't wanna get serious and say, okay, okay, hold it, hold it, okay, okay. Now let's, rolling please. Yeah, but she, I really have been such a fan for a long time.
不，我还没有这个荣幸。你根本什么都做不成，因为跟她一起玩太开心了。你不想变得严肃并说，好吧，好吧，等等，等等，好吧，好吧。现在我们，请开拍。对，但是她，我真的很崇拜她很久了。
I've seen almost everything she's done and I've always kind of felt like we'd be friends because she's so- I was just gonna say that. I don't have a lot of female friends, but if I could count three, she would be one of them. Why do you think that is? I don't know.
我看过她演的大部分作品，我一直觉得我们会成为朋友，因为她——我正想这么说呢。我没有很多女性朋友，但如果要数出三个，她会是其中之一。你觉得这是为什么？我不知道。
I do. Why? Uh-oh, why? Here it comes. Because I think that your personality is kind of grating. Okay, okay. No, no, listen, don't let him keep going, Shawn. No, that was it.
我知道。为什么？噢不，为什么？它来了。因为我觉得你的性格有点讨人嫌。好吧，好吧。不，不，听着，别让他继续说下去了，肖恩。不，就是这样。
No, no, that was it. That's a full stop. Oh, there wasn't a qualifier on that? Especially towards, it's grating towards women. Oh. Men tolerate it. Sorry, that should have said that. Towards women, I think women find your personality.
不，不，就是这样。这就说到这儿。哦，那句话没有限定条件吗？尤其是针对，对女性来说很讨人嫌。哦。男人能忍受。抱歉，刚才应该加上那句。针对女性，我觉得女性觉得你的性格。
So you're saying the reason I don't have a lot of female friends is because they don't wanna be friends with me. Yeah, yeah, exactly. Because of your personality. I thought I had a choice. I thought. I thought.
所以你的意思是，我没有很多女性朋友，是因为她们不想跟我做朋友？对，对，没错。因为你的性格。我还以为我有选择权呢。我以为。我以为。
I thought. I thought. I thought. I thought. Got it. Okay. Okay. That's not true.
我以为。我以为。我以为。我以为。明白了。好吧。好吧。这不是真的。
That's not true. By the way, that's not true. Is it at a level that I could maybe, could I work on it? Or is it a little too heavy? That's not for us. Work on your personality. You've been working on it for 52 years, pal.
这不是真的。顺便说一句，这不是真的。这严重到我可能需要，我能改进一下吗？还是说有点太严重了？那可不归我们管。改进你的性格。你都改进了52年了，老兄。
Sorry. What are you gonna do now? Okay. You know? No, I will say this. You have a lot of, you do have a lot of female friends. That's not true.
抱歉。你现在打算怎么办？好吧。你知道吗？不，我得这么说。你有很多，你确实有很多女性朋友。这不是真的。
You have Catherine. Yes, what do you mean? No, but I mean like close, tight, like just call them up. Like here's how my day's been going kind of thing. Well, like I have, as you know. You do? My wife's one of them.
你有凯瑟琳。是的，你什么意思？不，但我的意思是亲密的、紧密的，就是那种随时打电话的。就像“我今天过得怎么样”这种类型的。嗯，我有，如你所知。你真的有？我妻子就是其中之一。
Well, your wife is one of my close friends and she's a female and she and I talk on the phone or FaceTime often. Right. I am, I love Amanda. I am friends with both sexes because I am non-threatening. That's not, one of my favorite things that Sean does,
嗯，你妻子是我的密友之一，她是个女性，她和我经常通电话或FaceTime。没错。我，我很喜欢阿曼达。我和两性都是朋友，因为我没有威胁性。这不是，肖恩最喜欢的事情之一，
and he likes to do this a lot at dinner. He does this a lot at Jen's because Jen often has candles on the table, as we know for dinner. Sean, I'll go, he'll pick up one of the candles. And he goes, which way is the bathroom? He protects the candle like an old time.
他很喜欢在晚餐时这么做。他在詹（Jen）家经常这样做，因为我们知道詹晚餐时桌上经常有蜡烛。肖恩，我会走过去，他会拿起其中一支蜡烛。然后他说，洗手间在哪边？他护着蜡烛的样子就像个老派人物。
Like I'm screwed. Like yeah. Which way is the bathroom? And he walks like if he's going through like a haunted mansion. All this bit in the world. Or I'll pick up literally any purse that a woman left behind. I'll pick it up and go,
就像我死定了。就像，是的。洗手间在哪边？他走路的姿势就像在走鬼屋一样。全是这种烂梗。或者我会拿起任何一个女人落下的钱包。我会拿起来然后说，
I'm running to Ralph's. Anybody need anything? Remember we were at this dinner and Tyke has shown up and he had that, he had like Joseph's Technicolor coat and it was really. Shame coat, he had a lot of colors and stuff like that. And he came in and he put it on the chair.
我跑去劳尔超市了。有人需要什么吗？还记得我们参加的那次晚宴吗，泰克（Tyke）出现了，他穿着那件，他穿着约瑟夫的彩色大衣，真的很。耻辱大衣，他有很多颜色之类的。然后他走进来，把它放在椅子上。
And then Sean and Scott, he got up to leave like 20 minutes later and all of a sudden, Sean comes in the room and Sean's wearing it. He goes, anyway, guys, I'm going, Tyke goes, hang on a second. And he goes, I came with this.
然后肖恩和斯科特，他大约20分钟后起身要走，突然间，肖恩走进了房间，肖恩正穿着它。他说，总之，伙计们，我要走了，泰克说，等一下。然后他说，我是穿着这个来的。
I walked in with this. He went, I walked in with this. He's a nice guy. Tyke Latiti. Gosh, he's talented. Anyway, Catherine Hahn. Let me just say, Sean, thank you for getting Catherine on the show.
我是穿着这个走进来的。他是个好人。泰克·维迪提（Taika Waititi）。天哪，他太有才了。总之，凯瑟琳·哈恩。我只想说，肖恩，谢谢你把凯瑟琳请到节目上来。
Yeah. She is one of those just mega wattage talents. And I meant it that she is always, always good. It's so good. It's so true. And you know what? There's, there aren't, like you said,
对。她就是那种具有超级瓦数天赋的人。我是说真的，她总是、总是那么棒。太棒了。千真万确。你知道吗？没有，就像你说的，
there aren't a lot of actors out there that it doesn't matter what the material is. If it's the material is great or it's just kind of not so great. She always shines in everything. I couldn't agree with you more. And I think she's just hilarious. Hilarious.
没有多少演员能做到无论剧本是什么样。无论剧本是好极了还是有点不太好。她在每部作品里都光芒四射。我不能更同意你的看法了。而且我觉得她太搞笑了。太搞笑了。
She really is. She just sparkles. And a really, in a really, really nice person too. Like a very genuine, nice person, real family. Nice talent that people work a lot. Forget working with, even just hanging out with her, it's almost impossible. Like this interview was tough,
她真的是。她整个人都在发光。而且也是个非常、非常nice的人。就像一个非常真诚、nice的人，真正的顾家。这种很有天赋的人片约不断。别说合作了，光是跟她一块儿消磨时间，都几乎是不可能的。就像这次采访一样艰难，
just getting through because she's so much fun and you just want to laugh and just have a conversation. Yeah. It's like we were at a restaurant or something. Yeah. You never want to get serious. Yeah. I love it.
光是熬过去就很不容易，因为她太好玩了，你只想笑，只想跟她聊天。对。就像我们在餐厅或者什么地方一样。对。你永远不想正经起来。对。我太喜欢了。
I, her, if she ever had an autobiography, she should call it, honestly. Uh-huh. Oh, I get it. I get it. I get it. And that would be the title of her. Yiee.
我，她如果有一天写自传，她应该把它叫做“说实话”。嗯哼。哦，我懂了。我懂了。我懂了。那就会是她的书名。呀。
Bye. Autobi. Oh, look at me. All right. Smart. Smart. Smart. Last.
再见。自传。哦，看看我。好吧。聪明。聪明。聪明。最后。
SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjalf, and Bennett Barbaco. Smart. Last. Our next episode will be out in a week, wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music, or early and add free by subscribing to Wondery
SmartLess 是由迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）、罗布·阿姆贾尔夫（Rob Armjalf）和贝内特·巴巴科（Bennett Barbaco）100% 有机手工制作的。Smart。Last。我们的下一期节目将在一个星期后发布，无论你在哪里听播客，或者你现在就可以去亚马逊音乐（Amazon Music）抢先收听，或者通过在苹果播客（Apple Podcasts）或 Wondery App 上订阅 Wondery Plus 来抢先收听并免广告。
Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。